Oh, it's so cold in here. Is anyone else cold, or is it just me? I mean, like... Oh, it's... Oh, God, it's... Oh, God, it's a cold. Oh, Lord, it's like a cold... There's nothing colder than a cold open.
哦，这里太冷了。还有人觉得冷吗，还是只有我觉得冷？我的意思是……哦，这……哦，天哪，这……哦，天哪，这是个冷开场。哦，天哪，这就像一个冷开场……没有什么比冷开场更冷的了。
Snakes! This is a cold open. Ah, now I'm getting bit by a snake. Everybody run. The snakes are cold. It's a cold open. Oh, my phone is ringing. Hang on one second.
蛇！这是一个冷开场。啊，现在我被蛇咬了。大家快跑。蛇很冷。这是一个冷开场。哦，我的电话在响。等一下。
It's time for a cold open. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Listener... Oh, we're talking about the Golden Globes. Yeah, we were talking about the Golden Globes. Yeah. And it was fun.
是时候来个冷开场了。欢迎来到Smartless。聪明的。听众……哦，我们在谈论金球奖。对，我们刚才在谈论金球奖。对。而且很有趣。
We had a good time, us guys. We did that fun. That was... That was super fun. We did our sweaty bit at the beginning. It was great. It was super fun. Nice to be a part of that...
我们玩得很开心，我们这些家伙。我们做了那件有趣的事。那是……超级有趣。我们在开始时做了那个流汗的段子。太棒了。超级有趣。很高兴能成为其中的一部分……
What was it? I guess category. And as our friend, Jimmy Kimmel put it, nice to be a part of that category because it could end up like break dancing at the Olympics. and no one ever sees it again. Break dancing at the Olympics.
那是什么？我猜是奖项类别。正如我们的朋友吉米·金梅尔所说，很高兴能成为那个类别的一部分，因为它最后可能会像奥运会上的霹雳舞一样，再也没有人能看到了。奥运会上的霹雳舞。
The last time you see that category, I don't know. But congrats to Miss Amy Poehler for winning. The absolute best podcast in the world. Yeah, congrats to her. Good hang did very well. It was a good hang. Her speech was a good hang. Yeah, a lot of good speeches last night.
你最后一次看到那个类别是什么时候，我不知道。但祝贺艾米·波勒小姐获奖。世界上绝对最好的播客。对，祝贺她。是一次很好的聚会，非常成功。聚会感觉很好。她的演讲感觉很好。对，昨晚有很多精彩的演讲。
You know what's fun about... I saw Amy right before. I saw Amy and Joel in the thing in the back. and she was like oh my god you guys are going to win i go bull eff and shit yeah we've been saying everybody win for months i won 200 bucks i bet i bet on her and won two hundred dollars i know you bet with krasinski and then i said i told amy that you bet with krasnski and i go right from moment one you know that she's got it locked up when it comes to that
你知道有什么有趣的吗……我在后台刚刚看到了艾米。我看到艾米和乔尔在后面的那个地方，她当时说，哦，天哪，你们要赢了，我说，胡扯个屁啊，真的，我们几个月来一直在说每个人都会赢，我赢了200块钱，我押她赢了，赢了两百块钱，我知道你跟卡辛斯基下注了，然后我说，我告诉艾米你跟卡辛斯基下注了，我说从一开始，你就知道她稳操胜券，当谈到那个的时候
like she's she's beloved she deserves it but she's beloved yeah for sure for sure But anyways. Did you guys meet anybody you were excited to meet last night? Did you have anybody come up? I had a wonderful conversation with Kevin Bacon and Sean Penn. Yeah. Those guys are great, yeah. Willie, did you get some nice compliments on your film?
就像她，她备受喜爱，她实至名归，但她备受喜爱，是的，当然，当然，无论如何。昨晚你们有没有遇到什么让你们感到激动的人？有没有人过来打招呼？我和凯文·贝肯以及肖恩·潘进行了一次愉快的交谈。是的。那些家伙很棒，是的。威利，你的电影有没有得到一些好评？
I did, actually. Yeah, it was nice. There was a lot of nice people said a lot of people that I really look up to and that I'd love some of those things. Yeah. Yeah, George was very nice about it. Yeah, he was very sweet about it. He sent me a nice text as well.
其实是的。是的，感觉很好。有很多很好的人说了许多话，那些我真的很尊敬、我很喜欢其中一些事情的人。是的。是的，乔治对此非常好。是的，他对此非常贴心。他还给我发了一条很棒的短信。
Sandler and those guys super nice and had some good had some good laughs at one point Jason was bothering me pretending that he was working at the after party
桑德勒和那些家伙超级好，有一刻我们笑得很开心，当时杰森一直在烦我，假装他在派对后继续工作
and he just kept bothering pretending that he was running running the martini card he was running a martini card he goes I'll just be right here if you want anything I have vodka and gin vodka and gin
他一直烦我，假装他在管理、管理马提尼酒车，他在管理一台马提尼酒车，他说，如果你想要什么，我就在这儿，我有伏特加和金酒，伏特加和金酒
like into my ear and I just kept going would you fuck off that's hilarious Seanie Everything's okay Sean had to leave early Some sort of an ailment
像是在我耳边说，我一直说，你他妈的滚开吧，太搞笑了，肖尼，一切都好，肖恩不得不早点离开，某种小病
It's funny how it timed out right to us losing our category That is emergency cropped up Crazy who could have called that It was unfortunate timing But everything was all taken care of He got home in time To end up being okay Evacuate whatever was
好笑的是，时间掐得刚刚好，正好赶上我们输掉奖项类别，紧急情况就出现了，太疯狂了，谁能料到呢，时机真是不巧，但一切都得到了妥善处理，他及时赶回家，最后没事了，撤离还是什么的
Yeah No thank you for your concern Thank you yeah I know everything was turned out terrific Yeah I was just like you know It's super fun to go. The show Will and Grace, the Will and Grace program, and myself and all the cast and everybody. Now that's a comedy.
对，不，谢谢你的关心，谢谢，我知道一切结果都好极了，是的，我当时就想，你知道的，去参加超级有趣，节目《威尔与格蕾丝》，《威尔与格蕾丝》节目，还有我自己以及所有的演员和每个人，那才叫喜剧。
Bring it back. Because he's gay, so they can't be together. But they're best friends. But they would be perfect together. But he's gay. Boy, this guy's astute. He's got a real take on Will and Grace. the guy in the back of the pier.
把它带回来。因为他是同性恋，所以他们不能在一起。但他们是最好的朋友。但他们本是绝配。但他是个同性恋。天哪，这家伙太精明了。他对《威尔与格蕾丝》有独到的看法。码头后面的那个家伙。
That is so funny. But anyway, we've been nominated a total of 27 times. No way. Yeah, and then last night was 28, and we never won one. Is that true? Yeah, never won.
太搞笑了。不过不管怎样，我们一共被提名了27次。不会吧。对，然后昨晚是第28次，我们一次都没赢过。真的吗？对，从来没赢过。
Wait, Will and Grace was up for what last night? No. I'm just saying total, and then last night was one more that I and the three of us. Oh, that you were a part of it. Gotcha, gotcha. That's 28 and 0, 0 and 28 at the Golden Globes?
等等，《威尔与格蕾丝》昨晚入围了什么？没有。我只是说总共，然后昨晚是我们三个人的又一次提名。哦，你是其中一部分。明白了，明白了。那是28战0胜，金球奖0胜28负？
That is correct. Something like that, 26, 27. I was there, Jay 1-1. I was sitting next to Jay 1-1. I was sitting next to Jay and we had a nice deep... Oh, that's nice. For what? For what?
没错。差不多吧，26、27次。我在那儿，Jay 1-1。我坐在Jay 1-1旁边。我坐在Jay旁边，我们进行了一次愉快而深刻的交谈……哦，那挺好。为了什么？为了什么？
For Ozark? This was for arrested. Oh, that's great. Congratulations. Yeah, yeah. I made the mistake of thanking every single person I've ever met in my life. No, you know what? I remember that night.
为了《黑钱胜地》？这是为了《发展受阻》。哦，那太棒了。恭喜。是的，是的。我犯了个错误，感谢了我一生中遇到的每一个人。不，你知道吗？我记得那个晚上。
I was really sweet and you were legitimately surprised and it was a... That was a really, really fun night. I don't have to look that up. I'd like to see that. Yeah. You get to have those fun movies. Nice things don't usually happen for me. Oh, I know.
我真的很贴心，你当时真的很惊讶，那是一个……那真的是非常非常有趣的一夜。我不需要去查那个。我很想看看。是的。你得经历那些有趣的时刻。美好的事情通常不会发生在我身上。哦，我知道。
I know. We're... Everybody's real concerned about it. You've had a rough road. I was proud of our little bit, the three of us. You know, we were cooking with gas up there. That's right. By the way, and I said to Jason, nobody in the history of an award show has done a bit with
我知道。我们……每个人对此都很关注。你这一路走来很不容易。我为我们的小段子感到骄傲，我们三个。你知道，我们在上面干得热火朝天。没错。顺便说一句，我对杰森说，颁奖典礼历史上从来没有人做过这样的段子：
their back towards the audience. I know. It was so good. J.B., that was so great. Try to create a private moment. It was so funny. That was fun. laughing at that. I liked Clooney's and
把背对着观众。我知道。太棒了。J.B.，那太棒了。试图创造一个私密的时刻。太搞笑。那很有趣。嘲笑那个。我喜欢克鲁尼的
a bit with Don Cheeto, Cheelel. That was good. They were really good. Anyway, they were good. All right, here we go. Ready? Yeah. Yeah. My guest today is wonderful. She's fantastic. She's living proof that good things come to those who wait. She grew up in Adams, Tennessee, population 600.
和唐·钱德尔的段子。挺不错的。他们真的很棒。不管怎样，他们很好。好了，我们开始吧。准备好了吗？对。对。我今天的嘉宾很棒。她太棒了。她用活生生的事实证明，美好的事情总会降临在那些肯等待的人身上。她在田纳西州亚当斯长大，人口600人。
Whoa. Where her parents ran the only grocery meat shop in town. She hung around the local funeral home for fun. After college, she sold jewelry at house parties to help make ends meat. 25 years later, She's finally having her moment at 60, sold out arenas,
哇。她的父母在那里经营镇上唯一的杂货肉铺。她为了好玩而在当地的殡仪馆闲逛。大学毕业后，她在家庭聚会上卖首饰来维持生计。25年后，她终于在60岁时迎来了自己的高光时刻，座无虚席的体育场，
Netflix specials, best-selling memoir, hit sitcom. She's a self-proclaimed Mrs. Maisel of Appalachia. It's the hilarious big-hearted Leanne Morgan. I knew it. I knew it. I knew it.
Netflix特辑，畅销回忆录，热门情景喜剧。她是她自称的阿巴拉契亚的麦瑟尔夫人。她就是搞笑且热心的莉安·莫根。我早就知道。我早就知道。我早就知道。
I knew it. I knew it. I knew it. I know it was Leanne Morgan. I've never seen Will so happy. I've never seen Leanne's. I've been love with all of y'all. And I'm in a sinful way.
我早就知道。我早就知道。我早就知道。我知道是莉安·莫根。我从来没见过威尔这么高兴。我从来没见过莉安的。我爱你们所有人。而且是用一种罪恶的方式。
Yeah. Oh. Thank y'all for having me. This is a dream come true. Oh, it's so nice to have you here. For us too. For us too. Oh, my God.
Yeah. Oh. 谢谢你们邀请我。这简直是梦想成真。哦，很高兴你能来。对我们来说也是。对我们来说也是。哦，天哪。
I'm so happy. I love your story. I love that you are having this moment. It's so dessert. You're so funny and cool and original. Oh, I'm so psyched that you're here. Thank you, Will. Thank you.
我太高兴了。我喜欢你的故事。我喜欢你正在经历这个高光时刻。这是你应得的。你又搞笑又酷又独特。哦，我太高兴你能来了。谢谢你，威尔。谢谢。
Now I've got a beagle yelling at me. Hold on, boys. A beagle? A beagle? A beagle? A little beagle. I like beagles. I'm up on my top floor.
现在有一只小猎犬在对我大喊大叫。等等，伙计们。一只小猎犬？一只小猎犬？一只小猎犬？一只小猎犬。我喜欢小猎犬。我在我的顶层。
Yeah. And she doesn't like for me to talk on the phone. So let me get that out of the way. I'm sitting here in the foothills of the Smoky Mountains in Knoxville, Tennessee, and I love y'all. We love you. By the way, Leanne, when you said you had a beagle talking to you, Sean was thinking to himself at the same time,
对。而且她不喜欢我打电话。所以让我先把这事处理好。我正坐在田纳西州诺克斯维尔的大烟山山麓，我爱你们所有人。我们也爱你。顺便说一句，莉安，当你刚才说有一只小猎犬对你大叫时，肖恩同时心里在想，
he was like, I feel like there's a bagel talking to me from the kitchen, too. So you're Knoxville. Eat me. That's amazing. I mean, it is really cool. like Will said, to hear your story, and we'll get into this sec. But, like, I am so, I don't even know you,
他当时在想，我感觉厨房里也有一只百吉饼在对大叫。所以你是诺克斯维尔的。吃我吧。这太棒了。我的意思是，真的很酷。正如威尔所说，听到你的故事，我们一会儿会深入聊聊。但是，我真的，我甚至都不认识你，
and I'm so excited for you for all that's happening here. Thank you. It's really, really cool. I've seen you, first of all, congrats on your, I know your show has been this super big hit. So congrats on that. Thank you. And then now you, you, did you just have a special, a Netflix special?
我为你发生的一切感到非常兴奋。谢谢。真的很酷。首先，我看到你，祝贺你的节目大获成功。所以祝贺你。谢谢。然后现在你，你，你刚刚推出了一个特辑，一个Netflix特辑？
Yeah, it was in the top 10. Yeah, it's like, exactly. Like, you're just having all this stuff. And then I've seen you on a couple of interviews, and you've got a great, I watched a little bit of your you're on with Conan and it was so funny
对，它进入了前10名。对，就像，没错。就像，你正在经历所有这些事情。然后我在几个采访中看到过你，你有一个很棒的，我看了一点你在柯南节目里的表现，太搞笑了
God we like that Conan we love Conan any of the best I know he was wonderful I mean this guy's working with nothing he has so little talent and then he's managed to like kind of stay smooth yeah stay smooth and kind of scotch something together this dude it's amazing yep it's all repetitive
天哪，我们喜欢那个柯南，我们爱柯南，他是最好的我知道他很棒我的意思是这家伙什么都没有却在工作，他的才华那么少，然后他设法保持冷静，是的，保持冷静，把一些东西拼凑在一起，这家伙，太神奇了，是的，全都是重复的
but it works it is and to think about how little intellect he has and yet he's able to kind of make it work work yeah it makes the hair dance a little bit and he distracts you His hair. I know. I know. Blew me away.
但它管用，确实如此，考虑到他智力那么低，却还能让事情行得通，行得通，是的，这让头发有点跳舞，而且他转移了你的注意力，他的头发。我知道。我知道。震撼了我。
Wait, Leanne, so tell me, like, to what Will just said, why do you think, what do you, why do you think you are hitting at this time right now in your life, in this business, and all of it? What do you think is going on? Oh, my Lord. I don't know, boys. I guess, okay. I guess, you know, I've been doing stand-up for 20 years when this hit.
等等，莉安，告诉我，就像威尔刚才说的，你觉得为什么，你觉得为什么此时此刻，在你人生的这个阶段、这个行业以及这一切中，你会突然爆红？你觉得发生了什么？哦，天哪。我不知道，伙计们。我想，好吧。我想，你知道的，这事火的时候，我已经在做单口喜剧20年了。
I was in my early 50s. It's so good. And I think that, I mean, I was doing the same stuff. I'd always been doing. And one time I was backstage with Reba McIntyre's ex-husband, Norville. And he said... No, we know Norville well. Norville?
我当时50岁出头。太棒了。而且我认为，我的意思是，我一直在做同样的事情。有一次我在后台和雷巴·麦肯泰尔的前夫诺维尔在一起，他说……不，我们很了解诺维尔。诺维尔？
Yeah. That has Blake Shelton and all these people, Kelly Clarkson, and he said, it's just a phenomenon, Leon. Like, you've been doing the same thing for 20 years and you, you know, changing up my material, you know, all that. But doing stand-up and then this hits, it's like somebody turned a light on in a dark room. But I started doing that social media. thing, y'all. I found my audience, and I think that I
对。旗下有布莱克·谢尔顿和所有这些人，凯莉·克拉克森，他说，这简直是个奇迹，莉安。就像，你20年来一直在做同样的事情，你，你知道的，改变我的素材，你知道，所有这些。但做单口喜剧然后这个火了，就像有人在黑暗的房间里打开了一盏灯。但我开始做那个社交媒体，
found a niche, a demo, I don't know what you'd call, you Hollywood boys would call it, but a bunch of people that were probably being ignored by Hollywood. I think that. And I think I spoke to all these darling people that love to be entertained, buy tickets to theaters, and have been wonderful to me. And they like my sitcom, and they watch my specials. They love your sitcom. By the way, these guys are, I'm from Toronto, I'm just a kid. I'm just an Oshack's kid from Toronto, it should be noted.
事情，各位。我找到了我的受众，而且我认为我找到一个细分市场，一个受众群体，我不知道你们好莱坞的人会怎么称呼它，但有一群人可能一直被好莱坞忽视。我是这么想的。而且我认为我跟所有这些可爱的人对话了，他们喜欢被娱乐，购买剧院门票，并且对我一直很好。他们喜欢我的情景喜剧，他们看我的特辑。他们喜欢你的情景喜剧。顺便说一句，这些家伙是，我是从多伦多来的，我只是个孩子。我只是个来自多伦多的奥沙克斯小孩，这应该指出的是。
I'm just a Canadian kid. Yeah, we'll fill in all the Hollywood stuff for you guys. Sean, we got you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But, you know, it is interesting that I think our buddy Judd Apatow explained why comedy movies are not doing as good of business nowadays is because social media, there's these great little bite-sized moments of comedy that people, people kind of get satisfied by.
我只是个加拿大孩子。对，我们会为你们填补所有好莱坞的空缺。肖恩，我们罩着你。对，对，对。但是，有趣的是，我们的好友贾德·阿帕图解释了为什么喜剧电影现在票房表现不佳，是因为社交媒体上有这些很棒的小块头喜剧时刻，人们从中得到了满足。
And it is great. I mean, I'm looking at them too. I'm laughing my ass off. And it does seem like... And it's immediate, right? Yeah, but it is helping some parts of the business and maybe hurting others, or I don't know, but it is... I think it hurts.
而且这确实很棒。我的意思是，我也在看。我笑得前仰后合。而且看起来……而且它是即时的，对吧？对，但它确实在帮助这个行业的某些部分，也许在伤害其他部分，或者我不知道，但它确实……我认为它有伤害。
I do. I love a comedy. I love a movie. I was in a... I've only done one movie, and I played Reese With With With With Wetherstone's Big Sister, Gwendoff. With Will Ferrell. With Will Ferrell. Yeah, that's great.
确实如此。我喜欢喜剧。我喜欢电影。我演过一……我只演过一部电影，我在里面饰演瑞丝·威瑟斯彭的大姐格温多夫。和威尔·法瑞尔一起。和威尔·法瑞尔一起。对，那很棒。
He was darling, and we had a ball. But I miss movies like that. I love all of Judd Apatose movies. I mean, I just, yeah, and I do. I think there's these little snippets, and then people just get satisfied with that. Yeah. And let me tell you all that my sitcom made it to number two on Netflix
他很可爱，我们玩得很开心。但我怀念那样的电影。我喜欢贾德·阿帕图的所有电影。我的意思是，我只是，是的，而且我确实觉得有这些小片段，然后人们就对此感到满足了。对。让我告诉你们所有人，我的情景喜剧在Netflix上排到了第二名，
because the hunting wives came out the same time. All those girls that were shooting boars in their panties. Did y'all ever watch that show? No, what happened? No, what is it? It's hunting wives. They'll shoot a wild boar in panties. They were shooting boars in their panties, James.
因为《猎妻》和它同时上映。所有那些穿着内裤射野猪的女孩。你们看过那个节目吗？没有，怎么回事？没有，那是什么？是《猎妻》。她们穿着内裤射野猪。她们穿着内裤射野猪，詹姆斯。
Jason's like, what channel? And then would do sexual stuff with each other, and I could not beat that. You know, a multi-line could not be that. How do you spell hunting? Sorry. I may internet's slow here, but... Is that true? I have heard of the hunting wives, but I haven't seen it yet.
杰森说，哪个频道？然后彼此做一些性行为，而我无法打败那个。你知道，多机位喜剧无法击败那个。狩猎怎么拼？抱歉。我的网络这里很慢，但是……真的吗？我听说过《猎妻》，但我还没看呢。
Is that what we can look forward to if we sample that? I mean, yeah. I think you would enjoy it, Jason, in the privacy of your own home. And then my special unspeakable things, that's the one that just came out. The first one was I'm every woman. And I could not believe Netflix gave me a special,
如果我们去看那个，我们能期待看到这些吗？我的意思是，是的。我想你会喜欢的，杰森，在你自己的私密空间里。然后我的特辑《难以言说的事》，那是刚出的那部。第一部是《我即女人》。我简直不敢相信Netflix会给我一个特辑，
me being, you know, out of the middle. Were they both in the top ten? Yes. Yeah, that's so amazing. That's so good. Deservidly so. It's funny as hell. Yeah.
我作为一个，你知道的，来自中间地带的人。它们都进入前十名了吗？是的。对，太惊人了。太棒了。实至名归。搞笑得要命。对。
Thank you. Thank you. But so then you think. I think that perhaps the bits that you were releasing onto social media, they caught fire a bit. And then did you then see attendance at your stand-up gigs get larger? And Netflix took notice of that. And then they said, okay, now you get a special?
谢谢。谢谢。但接着你认为。我想也许你在社交媒体上发布的段子，它们有点火了。然后你看到你的单口喜剧现场观众变多了吗？然后Netflix注意到了这一点。然后他们说，好吧，现在你有一个特辑了？
Is that the way that yes? That's exactly what happened. And then that special brings even more people. And then there's another special. That's the way it comes. Yeah. Jason works in business affairs, so he's trying to figure out of the commerce here. At what point was the big negotiation?
是这样吗？这正是发生的事情。然后那个特辑带来了更多的人。然后又有了另一个特辑。事情就是这样来的。对。杰森从事商业事务，所以他试图弄清楚这里的商业逻辑。大谈判是在什么时候进行的？
Was it before the first special or after? How far apart were you guys on your first offer? I think what turned it around, I was at, I could not get arrested. I always say that. I could not sell tickets in Clums. I was in my early 50s. I already felt like it was over. And then Clums would say, we love her, but she can't sell tickets.
是在第一个特辑之前还是之后？你们在第一份报价上的差距有多大？我想转折点是，我当时，我简直一事无成。我总是这么说。我在克拉姆斯的票根本卖不出去。我当时50岁出头。我甚至觉得一切都结束了。然后克拉姆斯会说，我们喜欢她，但她卖不出票。
And I was just about to give up. And then I put out a clip of me taking my husband, Chuck Morgan, to go see Def Leopard and Journal. and how everybody looked sick and had planter fasciitis. And that went viral, and then I think people saw that, and they were like, what else does she have? Everybody looks at it. And had platterfaciitis.
我当时正准备放弃。然后我发布了一段视频，内容是我带我的丈夫查克·莫根去看黛芬·勒帕德和杰尼乐队，
That is a rough crowd. Because of the way he walks, is that what it is? Oh, the little boys in journey, you know. Yeah. Well, they've heard that little guy, that little young guy, and he can still flip and squat and stuff, but those old boys. And then Depp Lampert came out.
那绝对是一群很难搞的观众。因为他走路的姿势，是这样吗？哦，杰尼乐队的那些小伙子们，你知道的。对，他们听说了那个小个子，那个年轻小伙，他仍然可以翻跟头和深蹲什么的，但那些老家伙。然后黛芬·勒帕德出来了。
And I thought, he had a little bump underneath his little chest. What, Jason? Is it Benson Boone? Is that the flipping squatter? Oh, no, he's a skipper in squatter. But no, the little, they've hired Journey, you know, because Steve Perry had a hip replacement. And maybe they even fell out.
我以为，他的小胸脯底下有一个小肿块。什么，杰森？是本森·布恩吗？是那个会翻跟头和深蹲的人吗？哦，不，他是会跳跃和深蹲的。但不，那个小个子，他们雇了杰尼乐队，你知道的，因为史蒂夫·佩里做了臀部置换手术。也许他们甚至闹翻了。
Maybe somebody got mad and they fell out. But as we say in the South, but they've hired some little man that can sound like Steve Perry and he could still move. But all the old boys were in the back, you know, and had a blank stare, and you could... But then Jeff Leopard came out
也许有人生气了，他们闹翻了。但正如我们在南方所说，他们雇了一些能模仿史蒂夫·佩里声音的小个子男人，而且他还能动。但所有老家伙都在后面，你知道的，面无表情，你可以……但接着黛芬·勒帕德出来了，
and had like a little bump under... And I thought, he's got a hernia. What's Jeff Leopard, man? He's wearing yoga pants still? He has tiny legs. His legs were this big, and he had hair down to here, and you could see through it.
胸部下面有个小肿块……我在想，他有疝气吗？黛芬·勒帕德是什么人，伙计？他还在穿瑜伽裤吗？他的腿很细。他的腿只有这么粗，头发垂到这里，而且头发稀疏得都能看透。
And I thought... He could see through it. And I just... And I had never done that bit before, and I was going to Chattanooga, Tennessee, and I thought everybody's all right heard all this mess. I got to come up with something new. And I thought, oh, I'll tell them about me and Chuck Morgan going to see Deflebert and Journey. And then that's what did it.
我想……头发都能看透。我只是……我以前从未做过那个段子，我要去田纳西州查塔努加，我想每个人都听过这些乱七八糟的事了。我得想出点新东西。我想，哦，我要跟他们讲讲我和查克·莫根去看黛芬·勒帕德和杰尼乐队的事。然后就是那个成了爆点。
And then I got the big panty tour, boys. So then I found myself talking about my panties a lot. So I named it the big panty tour. And that, but that was all like coming out of COVID. So everything was booming and I was selling tickets. And then your daughter, You used to run your Facebook account during COVID because you didn't know how to unite, like a tech person,
然后我接到了大内裤巡演，伙计们。所以后来我发现自己总是在谈论我的内裤。所以我把它命名为“大内裤巡演”。那，但这都是在疫情之后发生的。所以一切都在蓬勃发展，我的门票卖得很好。然后你的女儿，
and that's when you discovered, like, oh. Yeah, oh, my kids were doing it until I hired these darling young guys who they had during COVID, they helped me. Yeah, yeah. And I was on my back porch, you know, eating chicken and dressing. Well, I don't even want to say that in front of y'all
你在疫情期间曾让女儿帮你运营Facebook账号，因为你不会用，像个科技小白，也就是在那时你发现，哦。对，哦，我的孩子们一直在弄，直到我雇了这些可爱的年轻小伙子，他们在疫情期间帮了我。对，对，对。我当时在后廊上，你知道的，吃着鸡肉和填料。好吧，我甚至都不想在你们面前说这个，
because that's country. Like a chicken casserole and drinking wine. Too much wine. And then I went on tour and every picture of me at the Big Panty Tour, I looked sweaty. and heavy. And like I was just, like, chicken casserole was coming out of my pores.
因为这太乡土了。就像鸡肉砂锅配红酒。酒喝太多了。然后我开始巡演，在大内裤巡演中我的每张照片看起来都大汗淋漓。
And I had imposter syndrome and I was freaked out. And then Netflix bought that. And I did that special. And then, you know, Netflix is the stamp. I think Netflix is the stamp to say she's legit. This is a real deal. And that changed my life. That changed my life.
而且很重。就像我整个人，就像鸡肉砂锅从我的毛孔里喷出来一样。而且我有冒名顶替综合征，我当时吓坏了。然后Netflix买下了那个。我做了那个特辑。然后，你知道的，Netflix就是一个印章。我认为Netflix就是一个印章，证明她是合法的。这是来真的。这改变了我的生活。这改变了我的生活。
Yeah. And then Chuck Lurie came to my house in Knoxville, Tennessee. ask me if I would do a television show with him. And this was, and talk about though before that, there was four other like ones that didn't work for you. Like were they pilots or were they actual shows that went? I never shot a pilot, but I did. But I would be in Knoxville, Tennessee,
对。然后查克·洛尔来到我在田纳西州诺克斯维尔的家。问我是否愿意和他一起做一档电视节目。这之前，还有另外四个没成功的项目，你知道的，它们是试播集还是真正播出的节目？我从来没有拍过试播集，但我确实拍过。但我当时在田纳西州诺克斯维尔，
raising my three children. And I guess my first one, Warner Brothers and ABC, ABC bought it. And my children were in elementary and maybe one was in middle school. And I thought that was it. This was it. I'm going to be the next Roseanne. And then the writer strike hit. That first writer strike hit,
抚养我的三个孩子。我猜我的第一个项目，华纳兄弟和ABC，ABC买下了它。我的孩子们在上小学，可能还有一个在初中。我当时以为那就是全部了。就是这个了。我要成为下一个罗斯安。然后编剧罢工爆发了。第一次编剧罢工爆发了，
and it was over in a day. In 07. So that was a while ago. Yeah. And then I got two or three more. You know, you get them mixed up. Some of them I think could have gone somewhere. Some of them I don't think we're ever going to go anywhere.
一天就结束了。在07年。所以那是很久以前的事了。对。然后我又拿到了两三个。你知道的，你把它们搞混了。其中一些我认为本可以有所发展。其中一些我觉得永远都不会有什么进展。
But I didn't know. I'm not a Hollywood. You know, I don't know all that. But it's not the way it was supposed. That was not your story. This is your story, and this is kind of the best version of it, too. I think it's awesome. That was not your train, Leanne.
但我不知道。我不是好莱坞的人。你知道，我不懂那些。但事情本不该是那样的。那不是你的故事。这是你的故事，而且这也是最好的版本，我觉得太棒了。那不是你的列车，莉安。
This is your train. You're on it now. It's so exciting to watch and to see. And Jason has some follow-up questions about the chicken on the porch. Yeah, was it a white wine or was it a red wine? It was a red, Jason, in the middle of perimenopause that made that worse. You talking about wallering in the bed at night sweats. and y'all are asking each other, how did you sleep?
这是你的列车。你现在在上面了。看它发生和发展真是太令人兴奋了。杰森关于门廊上的鸡肉有一些后续问题。对，那是白葡萄酒还是红葡萄酒？那是红葡萄酒，杰森，处于围绝经期，这让情况更糟糕了。你说的夜里在床上翻来覆去出虚汗。你们俩还互相问，你睡得怎么样？
No, I know. Before I came on here. Not well. I know it. I know. And then, speaking about food, you celebrated your 60th birthday by going and eating two cakes with a fork at the grocery store. Is that right? Oh, my God.
不，我知道。在我上节目之前。睡得不好。我知道。我知道。说到食物，你庆祝60岁生日的方式是去杂货店用叉子吃两个蛋糕。是这样吗？哦，天哪。
We were in Florida, my favorite beach to go to. Chuck Morgan took me and all these kids and my two grandbabies. I've got two grandsons, a blonde and a redhead wheel, because I did Amy Polar, podcast, that doll, and she said, we've got, honey, we've got that too. Okay. And they took me down there, and we had a one, and they're toddlers. So we stayed in every night. It was wonderful.
我们在佛罗里达，我最喜欢的海滩。查克·莫根带着我和所有的孩子还有我的两个小孙子。我有两个孙子，一个金发一个红发，威尔，因为我上了艾米·波勒的播客，那个甜心，她说，我们有，亲爱的，我们也有那个。好的。他们把我带到那里，我们喝了一杯，他们是幼儿。所以我们每天晚上都待在里头。太棒了。
And then my kids bought me two birthday cakes from the grocery store, and I stood and ate them at the counter with a fork, with an old tankini swim skirt, lands in bathing suit boys. Wow. Yeah. Why did we get two? Because you have two favorites? Well, my kids, I've trained them.
然后我的孩子们从杂货店给我买了两百岁生日蛋糕，我穿着一件旧的坦克式泳裙底边，兰兹恩的泳衣，站在柜台用叉子吃它们。哇。对。我们为什么要买两个？因为你有两个最喜欢的？嗯，我的孩子们，我把他们训练出来了。
we overeat. But they were like, we know she likes chocolate, and the grandbabies like chocolate. And then we know that they, I think they wanted Chuck Morgan. He also likes a vanilla and a chocolate. So they said, let's get two.
我们吃得过多。但他们当时说，我们知道她喜欢巧克力，小孙子们也喜欢巧克力。然后我们知道他们，我想他们想要查克·莫根。他也喜欢香草和巧克力。所以他们说，买两个吧。
Because I've raised them that every day's a party. Right, right, right. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Can we just talk a little bit about Chuck Morgan because I love this idea of Chuck Morgan. I like hearing his full name every time.
因为我把他们抚养长大，觉得每一天都是派对。对，对，对。对。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。我们可以聊聊查克·莫根吗，因为我很喜欢查克·莫根这个概念。我喜欢每次都听到他的全名。
Yeah. I love it. Now, what's the deal with Chuck Morgan? He's a character, right? He's been a problem for some time. He's been a problem for some time. I met him at the University of Tennessee, honey. I had gone through a divorce and had smoked cigarettes and not gone to class, y'all.
对。我很喜欢。那么，查克·莫根到底是怎么回事？他是个奇葩，对吧？他有一段时间是个麻烦。他有一段时间是个麻烦。我在田纳西大学遇到他的，亲爱的。我当时刚经历了一场离婚，抽香烟，不上课，各位。
I hate to even say that to y'all. But I was a wrecked, dropped down. It's all voluntary when you get to college. You do whatever the hell you want, you know? And I was an idiot. And then I went back to finish, and I did, and then Chuck Morgan, I think, is attracted to people who are broken. And so we started dating. Not a lot of pushback from the broken folks.
我甚至讨厌对你们说这些。但我当时是一个彻底的废人，跌入谷底。上大学后一切都是自愿的。你想干嘛就干嘛，你知道的？我当时是个白痴。然后我回去完成学业，我做到了，然后查克·莫根，我想，被那些破碎的人吸引了。于是我们开始交往。这些破碎的人没有什么推卸责任的余地。
So we thought, let's merge this like Kmart and what was that, Sears, and let's just run it in the ground. But anyway, so Chuck Morgan and I marry. And then he buys a used mobile home business. He got an MBA. and he had never stepped in a mobile home, a trailer, and bought a mobile home business and moved me to the foothills of the Appalachia Mountains. All the while, y'all, knowing from the time I was little,
所以我们想，把这个像凯玛特和那个什么，西尔斯一样合并起来，然后把它搞垮。不管怎样，查克·莫根和我结婚了。然后他买下了一家二手移动房屋生意。他有MBA学位。却从未涉足过移动房屋、拖车，买下了一个移动房屋生意，把我搬到了阿巴拉契亚山脉的山麓。而所有这一切，各位，我从小就知道，
I'm going to be in show business, I'm going to be on television. I knew it from the time I was 10. Really? But I just didn't know how, you know, I was from the country and farming people. I didn't know how to, you know, I would have loved to have done the Groundleys or Second City. I was raised on Saturday Night Live. I would have loved to have done, but I just didn't know how.
我要进入演艺圈，我要上电视。我从10岁起就知道这一点。真的吗？但我只是不知道怎么做，你知道的，我来自乡下和农民家庭。我不知道怎么做，你知道的，我很想加入格朗德剧团或第二城剧团。我是看着《周六夜现场》长大的。我很想去，但我就是不知道怎么做。
You know, I was this little bitty country kid. And all through your 40s and 50s and all that, you still held on to that kind of thing that I'm still, it doesn't matter how long it takes I'm still going to do it. When I started, I called myself a true stand-up when Chuck sold that business and went to work for a big... Chuck Morgan. Berkshire Hathaway Company, Chuck Morgan.
你知道的，我只是个小小的乡村小孩。在你40多岁、50多岁以及所有这些时间里，你仍然坚持那种信念：我依然，不管花多长时间我依然会去做的。当我开始时，我称自己为一个真正的单口喜剧演员，当查克卖掉那家生意去为一家大公司工作时……查克·莫根。伯克希尔哈撒韦公司，查克·莫根。
And he moved me to San Antonio, and I would drive back and forth to Austin, Texas, where one of the best comedy clubs in the United States was in Austin and Jimmy Miller, who is Dennis Miller's brother. We know Dr. Jimmy Miller. He's got a PhD in showbiz. That's what I always say. We love Dr. Miller.
他把我搬到了圣安东尼奥，我会开车往返于德克萨斯州奥斯汀，美国最好的喜剧俱乐部之一就在奥斯汀，吉米·米勒，他是丹尼斯·米勒的兄弟。我们认识吉米·米勒博士。他有演艺圈的博士学位。我总是这么说。我们爱米勒博士。
The third brother owned that comedy club, and he's the one that sent my first CD, CD, to Hollywood to Jimmy, and he gave it to Tom Warner at Warner Brothers, and that's how I got that deal. Hey, Tom, Jimmy Miller. here. I got a hot CD for you. Tom's like, oh, great, sounds great. Thanks, Jimmy.
第三个兄弟拥有那个喜剧俱乐部，就是他把我的第一张CD，CD，寄到好莱坞给吉米，然后吉米把它交给了华纳兄弟的汤姆·华纳，我就是这样拿到那个合同的。嘿，汤姆，我是吉米·米勒。我这有一张劲爆的CD给你。汤姆说，哦，太棒了，听起来不错。谢谢你，吉米。
Two great guys. I was 32 when I started doing clubs and I considered myself a real. But I had been doing like little gigs in Marstown, Tennessee, in the Appalachia, like somebody say, can you come and do your program at the Rotary? And I would get paid $50, take my babies to Mom's Day Out and go do that. But I started doing clubs and, you know, being more like the real thing at 32 years old. Who was your hero coming up? Like, who are you looking at going, I'd love for my career to go that direction?
两个伟大的人。我32岁开始在俱乐部演出，我認為自己是个真正的喜剧演员。但我一直在田纳西州马斯敦的阿巴拉契亚地区做一些小演出，比如有人会说，你能来扶轮社做你的节目吗？我会得到50美元的报酬，带着我的宝贝们去妈妈日间托儿所，然后去演出。但我从32岁开始做俱乐部演出，你知道的，更像个真正的喜剧演员。你成长过程中的偶像谁？就像，你在看着谁时会想，我希望我的职业生涯也朝那个方向发展？
Was it somebody on a sitcom or was it a stand-up? I loved all sitcoms, but I loved stand-up. I loved Johnny Carson and watching the stand-ups. So I would watch, you know, Jay Leno, David Letterman. Remember David Brenner? Yeah. Yes. And Richard Lewis.
是情景喜剧里的人还是单口喜剧演员？我喜欢所有的情景喜剧，但我喜欢单口喜剧。我喜欢强尼·卡森，看单口喜剧。所以我会看，你知道的，杰·雷诺、大卫·莱特曼。还记得大卫·布伦纳吗？对。是的。还有理查德·刘易斯。
I love Richard Lewis. I would watch Ellen, Roseanne. When Roseanne was on there, it blew me away. But I loved sitcoms. I grew up watching WKRP in Cincinnati. Yeah, sure. And Cheers and Frasier and all that. But anything to do with, you know, comedy movies, stand up,
我喜欢理查德·刘易斯。我会看艾伦、罗斯安。罗斯安上节目时，震撼了我。但我喜欢情景喜剧。我是看着辛辛那提的《WKRP》长大的。对，没错。还有《干杯姐妹》和《欢乐一家亲》之类的一切。但任何与喜剧电影、单口喜剧有关的，
I loved all of it. And I just didn't know what I was going to do and how you can make a living at it. Yeah, yeah. Well, Guy, I'm going to go around the horn. What was everybody's favorite multi-capital? CAM sitcom of all time. All in the family.
我都喜欢。我只是不知道我要做什么以及如何靠它谋生。对，对。好吧，伙计们，我要轮流问一问。大家最喜欢的多机位情景喜剧是什么？《全家福》。
All in the family, you're number one? Yeah. Cheers for me too. Cheers for me too. Taxi was up there pretty good too. Yeah, I should say Will and Grace, but I... Oh, Will and Grace! Wait, which one was that?
《全家福》，你排第一？对。《干杯姐妹》对我也一样。《干杯姐妹》对我也一样。《出租车》也很不错。对，我应该说《威尔与格蕾丝》，但我……哦，《威尔与格蕾丝》！等等，那是哪一个？
No, no, I mean, because I was on it, so it would be something else, so it would be... No, it would be weird if you said if you... Yeah, that'd be gross. That's right. That's right. Let's just say, but yeah, cheers for me. Okay, sorry. Okay, sorry. Wait, what was your...
不，不，我的意思是，因为我演过它，所以会是别的，所以会是……不，如果你说的话会很怪……是的，那会很恶心。没错。没错。我们就说吧，但是，是的，《干杯姐妹》对我是。好吧，抱歉。好吧，抱歉。等等，你的……
Wait, wait, Leah, what was your favorite favorite of all of all the multi-camp it comes of all time. If you had to pick one, gun to head. I don't know why there'd be a gun to your head, but there is a gun to your head. I love Lucy. Oh gosh. Okay, y'all, let me think.
等等，等等，莉安，在所有多机位情景喜剧中，你最最喜欢的是哪一部？如果必须选一部，用枪指着头。我不知道为什么会有人用枪指着你的头，但确实有枪指着你的头。我爱露西。哦天哪。好吧，各位，让我想想。
I, does that, I really enjoyed WKRP in Cincinnati. There you go. I just loved it. I loved Lonnie Anderson. Les Nessman. I loved all those guys on radio. Gordon Jump.
我，真的吗，我真的很喜欢辛辛那提的《WKRP》。就是这样。我太喜欢了。我喜欢朗妮·安德森。莱斯·内斯曼。我喜欢广播里的那些人。戈登·容普。
When I think about it, or like Three's Company. I'm 60 years old. Oh, I love Three's Company. Yeah, it's company. Has a swinging door been more well used than in three's company. Oh, to the kitchen, that's what you, oh.
每当我想起它，或者像《三人行》。我60岁了。哦，我爱《三人行》。对，三人行。有没有哪扇旋转门比《三人行》里的使用得更频繁？哦，通往厨房的那扇，原来你是说这个，哦。
Right. LaGron and Shirley. Yeah, that was great. Yeah, that was swung pretty good too. Sure. So, wait, when you first started out, you were doing like Kiwanis Club stuff, right? Yeah. Community Center stuff.
对。劳模与雪莉。对，那也很棒。对，那扇门也转得挺好的。确实。所以，等等，你刚开始的时候，你是在做扶轮社那种活动，对吧？对。社区中心那种活动。
And did you know by those early shows? And then you were doing, I said in the intro, you were doing. Jewelry. Oh, like, oh, jewelry, right. Jewelry parties. Is that like Tupperware parties and stuff? Yes, I was selling, because Chuck Morgan, y'all, is tied with money. and people don't believe me when I say that.
你在那些早期的演出中就知道了吗？然后你在做，我在开场白里说过，你在做。珠宝。哦，像，哦，珠宝，对。珠宝派对。那就像特百惠派对之类的吗？是的，我在卖，因为查克·莫根，各位，对钱抠门。人们在我这么说时不相信我。
I remember that. We were just in New York celebrating my five-year-old grandbabies fifth birthday, and we took him to the Museum of Natural History and to the Lion King and all that. Chuck Morgan booked me in a Hilton Garden Inn. It's where Will is right now. Yeah, exactly.
我记得那个。我们当时在纽约庆祝我五岁小孙子的五岁生日，我们带他去自然历史博物馆、去看《狮子王》之类的一切。查克·莫根给我订了一家希尔顿花园酒店。就是威尔现在待的那家。对，没错。
But, you know, I kind of, I'm a big deal, but he likes to keep us, you know, with the break zone. But so I wanted to, of course, he was 27 years old, y'all, and had a business and was having to, you know, all these people on payroll. So I wanted to make a little money. I want to stay home and breastfeed my first baby. And I wanted to make a little money and get my hair highlighted. And then so one of my friends said, I'm selling this jewelry.
但是，你知道的，我，我是个大人物，但他喜欢把我们，你知道的，控制在预算之内。所以我想，当然，他当时27岁，各位，有一家公司，还必须，你知道的，给所有人发薪水。所以我想要赚点钱。我想呆在家里给我第一个孩子母乳喂养。我想赚点钱，去把头发挑染一下。然后我的一个朋友说，我在卖这个珠宝。
And I don't even care about jewelry. And she goes, you can meet people because I was isolated up in the Appalachia Mountain. She said, you can meet people. you can eat a D, eat some D, eat a brownie, sell some jewelry, get a, and so. By the way, I'm in. I just had a vision of you just now presenting a necklace with a little bit of dip underneath your fingernails. But, you know,
我甚至不在乎珠宝。她说，你可以认识人，因为我被隔离在阿巴拉契亚山脉。她说，你可以认识人。你可以吃点蘸酱，吃点布朗尼，卖点珠宝，得到一个，所以。顺便说一句，我加入。我刚刚脑海中浮现出你现在正展示一条项链，手指甲下面还沾着一点蘸酱的画面。但是，你知道，
Jason's thinking about other people touching the other vegetables and the dip or the chips, all the other fingers that get in there, right, Jay? A little bit. Oh, a double dipper. But, you know what, I look back. It was really fun, and I sold jewelry to everybody in the Appalachian Mountains because I was funny, and people thought they would book me about a year in advance because they would have a good time.
杰森在想其他人触摸其他蔬菜、蘸酱或薯片的情形，所有其他伸进去的手指，对吧，杰杰？有一点。哦，双重蘸酱。但是，你知道吗，我回想起来。真的很有趣，我把阿巴拉契亚山脉的每个人都卖遍了珠宝，因为我很搞笑，人们觉得他们会提前大约一年预定我，因为他们能玩得很开心。
I wouldn't talking about jewelry. I kind of developed some of my first material, and I was talking about breastfeeding and hemorrhoids. I always talk about what I'm going through, and women could relate to it. And then I remember saying to women, because you have to do the pitch at the end to book a party with me. And I said, I mean, it's see me in, get me now with a party,
我不是在谈论珠宝。我开始创作我的一些第一批素材，我谈论的是母乳喂养和痔疮。我总是谈论我正在经历的事情，女人们能够感同身受。然后我记得我对女人们说，因为你必须在最后做推销来跟我预定派对。我说，我的意思是，现在来看我、跟我定一个派对，
or see me in Las Vegas later. You're right. It's up to y'all. But I felt in my heart, y'all, I thought, I'll be on TV one day. I'm going to be on, you know, I'll be in Las Vegas. I'm going to be doing, which was crazy, but I thought that. I felt that every time. And then the company noticed, yes.
或者以后在拉斯维加斯看我。你说得对。由你们决定。但在我心里，各位，我想，我总有一天会上电视。我要上，你知道的，我要去拉斯维加斯。我要去表演，这太疯狂了，但我当时是这么想的。我每次都有这种感觉。然后公司注意到了，是的。
You have to see it. You have to see it to believe it. You really, really do. If you don't believe it, you know, no one else is going to. Yeah. It's so true. Yeah. And I always believed that I got real worried,
你必须看见它。你必须看见它才能相信它。你真的，真的必须如此。如果你不相信，你知道的，没有其他人会相信。太对了。对。而且我总是坚信，我曾经非常担心，
and right before I blew up, I told Chuck Morgan, I go, I don't think anything's going to happen. I feel desperate. I think I'm going to open up a hardware store. And he was like, that's crazy. And you don't need to do that, Lynn. And that's the first time I had doubt, and I almost quit. And then I said, these social media boys that I hired,
就在我爆红之前，我告诉查克·莫根，我说，我觉得不会发生什么了。我感到绝望。我想我要去开一家五金店。而他却说，这太疯狂了。你不需要那样做，莉安。那是第一次我有了怀疑，我差点就放弃了。然后我说，我雇的这些社交媒体小伙子们，
who are darling, I'm still with them. And I never spent that kind of money on my career and I thought I'm giving it three months because it was expensive. I thought I'm giving it three months. If nothing happens, I know that's a sign and I will bail out. And the first video they put out
他们太可爱了，我现在还跟他们在一起。我从来没有在我的职业生涯上花过那种钱，我想我给它三个月时间，因为它很贵。我想我给它三个月时间。如果什么都没发生，我知道那是个信号，我会退出。结果他们发布的第一个视频
went viral and changed everything. Let's kind of shout out to those boys. What are their names? Honest Fox Media and that is Jared and Andrew and they are precious. And I tell you, y'all, they had a mom. They grew up with a bunch of brothers and sisters, and they got my voice.
病毒式传播，改变了一切。让我们向那些小伙子们致敬。他们叫什么名字？Honest Fox Media，那是贾里德和安德鲁，他们太宝贵了。我告诉你们，各位，他们有一个妈妈。他们跟一堆兄弟姐妹一起长大，他们懂我的声音。
They understood my brand from the word go. That's great. What does Chuck Morgan think about the money you spent with Jared and the boys? He fought me on it. Yeah, of course he did. Classic Chuck Morgan. And I read that Chuck Morgan didn't realize how big your fame was until a gig at the University of Tennessee or something like that.
他们从一开始就懂我的品牌。太棒了。查克·莫根对你花在贾里德和那些小伙子身上的钱有什么看法？他跟我吵过。对，他当然会。典型的查克·莫根。我读到过，查克·莫根直到在田纳西大学或类似地方的一场演出，才意识到你的名气有多大。
You're walking out? Yeah, maybe when we went to see Lana Rinchie and Earth went in fire, and people, he got me regular tickets, which, you know, I don't mind sitting regular in somewhere. But now I got a bunch of darling, middle-aged women. You know, they've had a cocktail. And for you know it, I mean, we're all kissing and hugging, and I don't see the show. But anyway, people were yelling at me through that, at the big arena, and I think he was dumbfounded. Yeah, well, let's say more about that.
你走出来的时候？对，也许是我们去看莱昂内尔·里奇和地风火乐队的时候，人们，他给我买的是普通票，你知道的，我不介意坐在某处的普通座位。但现在我有一群可爱的、中年妇女。你知道的，她们喝了点鸡尾酒。不一会儿，我的意思是，我们都在亲吻拥抱，我根本看不到演出。但不管怎样，人们在那个大体育场里对我大喊大叫，我想他当时惊呆了。好吧，让我们多聊聊这个。
What happens, old big British is Chuck Morgan with his Berkshire halfway gig, and he's seeing Leanne. And you're jackassing it back to Austin and it's not for shits and giggles. You're really doing something and all of a sudden Chuck Morgan's in for a bit of a reality check. Security's getting between you and Chuck Morgan walking back out to the car
怎么回事，老查克·摩根（Chuck Morgan）跟他的伯克希尔半程演出，他见到了莉安。然后你像头驴一样赶回奥斯汀，可不是为了好玩。你是在干真事，突然之间，查克·摩根遭遇了一次现实的打击。安保人员插在你和查克·摩根中间，护送他走回车上
and he's not comfortable with that, is he? Well, some of it he loves, Jason. Some of it, I think it's been, it has been something to navigate. I think he does like to go to the University of Tennessee and set up in a box and meet Peyton Meaney. Yeah, of course he does. That doesn't suck, doesn't?
而他对此并不适应，对吧？嗯，有些部分他很喜欢，杰森。有些部分，我觉得，这确实需要一点摸索。我觉得他确实喜欢去田纳西大学，在一个包厢里坐下来，见到佩顿·梅尼。对，他当然喜欢。那感觉可不赖，不是吗？
Suck, does it old Chuckie Bump? Chuckie Bump. He has been a wonderful provider, so I think it was, you know, it was a little. We love Chuck Morgan. No, we love Cubs. It was hard for him for me to make, honey, to have this power. You know what I'm saying, boys?
不赖，对吧，老查基·邦普？查基·邦普。他一直是个出色的顶梁柱，所以我觉得，你知道，这有点……我们爱查克·摩根。不，我们爱查比。对我来说，亲爱的，拥有这种权力对他来说很难。你们懂我的意思吗，小伙子们？
Yeah, yeah. But, let me ask you just a little bit about you saying that Chuck Morgan got you the regular tickets, and you don't mind and stuff like that, but now people are yelling out. And that experience of like, because there is that thing of people that go, oh, look at those celebrities, they're over and that special thing. And now you're like, oh, I kind of get it a little. little bit. Because, right, a little bit?
对，对。但是，我想问你一点关于你说的，查克·摩根给你弄到了普通票，你也不介意之类的事，但现在人们在尖叫了。还有那种体验，因为人们会有一种心态，哦，看那些名人，他们在那里，还有那种特别的待遇。现在你会觉得，哦，我有点懂了。一点点。因为，对吧，就一点点？
Can you speak to that? Yeah. Because y'all, I mean, I have wonderful fans. And when I tell you, I go out in those theaters or arenas, and they stand up and blow me kisses for I've ever said a word. They're precious. They want to see me win. And I think a lot of women my age are, I think they tell me it's inspiring that this
你能谈谈这个吗？行。因为你们大家，我的意思是，我有很棒的粉丝。当我和你们说，我走到那些剧院或竞技场里，我甚至还没说一句话，他们就站起来给我飞吻。他们太可爱了。他们希望看到我成功。我觉得很多像我这个年龄的女性，他们告诉我这很鼓舞人心，
happened to me at this age and it's not over and all of that. But you never know if somebody's crazy. There could be somebody that's unhinged, you know, and you just don't know. And I didn't know that. I didn't know. So when I am, only when I'm in large crowds, they'll have somebody want with me. But Chuck goes, we don't need anybody, Lynn, I got it. And Chuck's a big man.
这事发生在我这个年龄，而且还没结束，诸如此类。但你永远不知道谁会是疯子。可能会有精神失常的人，你知道，你根本猜不到。我以前不知道。我不知道。所以当我在的时候，只有在人多的地方，他们才会安排人跟我在一起。但查克说：“我们不需要任何人，琳，我能搞定。”而且查克是个大高个。
He's six, four. He's grumpy, you know, he's pissed. Do you run stuff material by him at all? Like, you're like, are you, is this funny? Is this not, or does he not? No, I don't because he, now he'll say to me. You need to say that. Or tell him this, Leanne.
他身高六尺四。他脾气暴躁，你知道的，他很恼火。你会跟他过一下段子吗？比如，你会问他，这个好笑吗？这个不好笑吗？还是说他不管？不，我不会，因为他——现在他会跟我说：“你需要说那个。”或者“告诉他们这个，莉安。”
Like, he'll remember something and say, why don't you tell him that? And he's given, he gives me a lot of good material, y'all, because he's peculiar. What about your kids? Do your kids think you're funny? It's peculiar. They do. They do, Jason, but they're annoyed by me, too. Yeah, they do.
比如，他会想起什么然后说：“你为什么不告诉他们那个？”他给了我很多很好的段子素材，大家伙，因为他很古怪。那你的孩子们呢？你的孩子觉得你搞笑吗？这很古怪。他们觉得。他们觉得，杰森，但他们也觉得我很烦。对，他们觉得。
They'll go, girl, you're funny. But they also think I've gotten kind of diva. Yeah. Oh, do they? Yeah. Uh-huh. Well, they're all grown. They can cook.
他们会说：“妈，你真搞笑。”但他们也觉得我有点变成女高音歌唱家（大牌）了。对。哦，是吗？对。嗯哼。好吧，他们都长大了。他们会做饭。
You know? I get home. I've been on the road. Y'all are on the road. Y'all know you get home. You're exhausted. You're staring out into space. Could somebody else boil the macaroni?
你知道吗？我到家了。我一直在巡演。你们都在巡演。你们都知道回到家是什么感觉。你筋疲力尽。你两眼发直地发呆。难道别人就不能去煮个通心粉吗？
Right. Yeah, yeah. Mom's hammering it. And then when you were, you got, wait, how many kids do you have? Three. A boy and two girls. Right. And you said babies come first.
对。对，对。妈妈正在拼命干活。然后当你在的时候，你有了，等等，你有几个孩子？三个。一个男孩，两个女孩。对。你刚才说宝贝排在第一位，
comedy came third. So what, did you, was that implied that you're second or like, what second? Oh, Lord. I don't know. I didn't feel second. What would that be? I mean, being a wife, probably. Did I say that out of my butthole? Okay. So it's mom, it's mom, wife career. Yes. But now, but now, the kids are, the kids are out of the house, yes? Chuck's doing just fine. He's got a brand new chair that he loves. He can spend all day in that chair. Now he's good.
喜剧排在第三位。那是什么，你是说你是第二位吗？或者说，什么是第二位？哦，天哪。我不知道。我不觉得自己是第二。那会是什么？我的意思是，做一个妻子，大概吧。我是不是信口开河了？好吧。所以是妈妈，妈妈，然后是事业。是的。但现在，但现在，孩子们都离家了，对吧？查克过得很好。他有了一张他很喜欢的新椅子。他可以在那张椅子上坐一整天。现在他挺好的。
And so now do we get to move a career up to number one now? Yeah, it's number one now, Jason. There we go. And I feel bad because I am the mama, and they do still need me some. But yes, this is taking over everybody. You don't know what that. I live out in L.A. part of the year to shoot, and so I can't be there for, and I miss my family so badly,
所以现在我们可以把事业提升到第一位了吗？对，现在它是第一位了，杰森。这就对了。而且我感觉很糟糕，因为我是妈妈，他们确实还需要我一些。但是的，这已经占据了一切。你们不知道这……我一年有一部分时间住在洛杉矶拍戏，所以我无法陪在身边，我太想念我的家人了，
and they come out back and forth to see me and I'll go home. But, yeah, it's taking over everything. So wait, so this is the sitcom you're shooting out here, right? Uh-huh. Now, that schedule, that schedule does free you up quite a bit, doesn't it? That's a real nice schedule, those sitcoms, the Chuck Lorry world. Oh, Mama. Are you doing just four-day weeks over there?
他们会两头跑来看我，我也会回家。但是，是的，这一切占据了全部。等等，所以这就是你在那边拍的情景喜剧，对吧？嗯哼。现在，那个日程安排，那个日程安排确实让你清闲了不少，不是吗？那是个非常不错的日程，那些情景喜剧，查克·洛尔（Chuck Lorre）的世界。哦，妈妈。你那边是不是一周只工作四天？
No, we do. Well, we do a table read on Monday, and then, um, rehearsal Tuesday, Wednesday, and then pre-shoot Thursday, and then live audience Friday. Right. Have them slide that table read over to Friday right before you start shooting, and you can free up that Monday.
没有，我们做。好吧，我们周一进行剧本围读，然后呢，周二、周三排练，接着周四预拍，然后周五在现场观众面前录制。对。让他们把那个剧本围读挪到周五，就在你开始拍摄之前，你就能把周一空出来了。
You can spend more time in chat, Nuka. Yeah. Tell Chuck there's a new plan. Yeah, yeah. God. Oh, boy. Jay, you're going to run into Chuck Lurray like today, and he's going to be out of the driving range.
你就能在查克·努卡（Chunk Nuka，应为Chuck Morgan）身上花更多时间。对。告诉查克有个新计划。对，对。天哪。哦，天哪。杰伊，你今天就要撞上查克·洛尔了，他肯定会在练习场。
I mean, isn't that kind of so great that you're so used to a live studio, audience since you toured all. I mean, like, it's probably, yeah, it probably relaxes you, no? It does. And I, I'm telling y'all, this scared me to death. I always wanted this, you know, and then you're like, oh, my gosh, why did I wish for this?
我的意思是，你这么习惯现场演播室观众，因为你到处巡演，这难道不是很棒吗？我的意思是，这可能会，是的，这可能会让你放松，不是吗？确实如此。而且我，我告诉你们，这把我吓死了。我一直想要这个，你知道的，然后你会想，哦，天哪，我为什么要求这个？
Because at first, it was so stressful. And Kristen Johnston plays my sister, who is a pro. She's great. She's such a pro. And she has to sit and tell me what to do and had to do her job and then teach me. I was like, what is that? What are y'all talking about? So at first I was terrified.
因为一开始，压力太大了。克里斯滕·约翰斯顿（Kristen Johnston）扮演我的姐姐，她是个专业演员。她太棒了。她真是个专业人士。她得坐下来告诉我该做什么，做好她自己的工作，还得教我。我当时想，那是什么？你们在说什么？所以一开始我吓坏了。
And then, and Reese Witherspoon said to me, it's the best schedule in television land. It's the best thing you could do. And we shoot two weeks on, one week on, because of Chuck Lurie, that's the way he wants it. It used to be three. This is very, look, how great. Now, are you able to cross paths with the great director,
然后，瑞茜·威瑟斯彭（Reese Witherspoon）对我说，这是电视界最好的日程安排。这是你能做的最好的事。而且我们拍两周，休一周，因为是查克·洛尔，他希望这样。以前是三周。这非常，看，多棒啊。现在，你有机会和伟大的导演
Jimmy Burroughs at all? I have not met him yet, no. And I've heard of them say something about him. He's the greatest to me. I did have Andy Ackerman for an episode. Very good. Very good. And I love him, and I'm hoping I get him on some of these this season.
吉米·伯勒斯（Jimmy Burrows）合作吗？我还没见过他，没有。我听别人提起过他。在我看来他是最棒的。我有一集是安迪·阿克曼（Andy Ackerman）导的。非常好。非常好。我很喜欢他，我希望这季能让他再导几集。
I loved him. That was my favorite episode. Are you shooting over at Warner Brothers or are you over there at Netflix lot? Warner Brothers. On the Friends lot. I mean, on the Friends soundstage. And do you rely on a lot of your own family stories to write stories for the show? No, not really.
我很喜欢他。那是我的最爱的一集。你们是在华纳兄弟（Warner Brothers）拍摄，还是在网飞（Netflix）的片场？华纳兄弟。在《老友记》片场。我的意思是，在《老友记》的录音棚里。你会依赖很多自己的家庭故事来为节目写剧本吗？不，其实没有。
I mean, they listen to every podcast. read my book, watched all my stand-up. So it's based on my stand-up. But, I mean, they'll get ideas for me, but not, I mean, I've got a really, I got Nick Backeye. Because when I was reading it, when I was reading about your stuff, all your family stories are so fucking funny. Can you say the one about the ski trip and one of your kids getting hurt?
我的意思是，他们听每一个播客，读我的书，看我所有的单口喜剧。所以这是基于我的单口喜剧。但是，我的意思是，他们会从我这里获得灵感，但不是……我的意思是，我有一个真的，我有尼克·巴卡伊（Nick Bakay）。因为当我阅读的时候，当我读到关于你的事情时，你所有的家庭故事都他妈的太搞笑了。你能讲讲滑雪之旅那次，你的一个孩子受伤的事吗？
Oh, when I fell off the ski left, are you talking about when I fell off at 49 years old? No, one of your kids, well, no, yeah, that, but one of your kids scared up, you know, shared a personal observation about themselves. Oh, are you talking about when the baby, who is my makeup artist, who is my true makeup artist on tour, she says now she's my caregiver and she hates that. But she's also my makeup artist on the set at Warner Brothers. Right.
哦，当我从滑雪缆车上摔下来时，你是说我49岁那年摔下来的时候吗？不，你的一个孩子，呃，不，对，那个，但是你的一个孩子吓坏了，你知道的，分享了关于他们自己的个人观察。哦，你是说那个宝贝，她是我的化妆师，她在巡演时是我真正的化妆师，她说现在她是我的护理员，她很讨厌这样。但她也是我在华纳兄弟片场的化妆师。对。
Is your youngest kid? The baby, uh-huh. And she's been a bugger. I'll just tell y'all. I'm in love with her. And she's funny. She's so funny. and she has been like Chuck Morgan.
是你最小的孩子吗？那个宝贝，嗯哼。她一直是个小淘气。我直说好了。我爱死她了。她很搞笑。她太搞笑了，而且她一直很像查克·摩根。
She's a lot like her daddy. Very strong wheeled. She's been a lot. And we were in Beaver Creek, Colorado. She was, and I think it was one of the two or three times we had been already. All right, everybody goes off skiing. This baby is on the gondola with me to go up to the bunny slope, which is not far to get up on that.
她很像她爸爸。非常有主见。她有很多次。我们当时在科罗拉多州的比弗克里克（Beaver Creek）。她当时，我想那是我们去过两三次中的一次。好吧，大家都去滑雪了。这个宝贝和我一起坐吊车去初学者雪道，去那个雪道并不远。
And it's just me and her. And in that short amount of time, she takes all of her clothes off. Yeah, she's hot. And, you know, skin. is hard. I've never enjoyed it. Chuck Morgan loves it. It's like I compared it to working in a coal mine. When I go skiing because I got to get everybody dressed,
当时就我和她。就在那么短的时间里，她把所有的衣服都脱光了。对，她很热。而且，你知道，滑雪服很难穿。我从来没享受过。查克·摩根很喜欢。这就像我把它比作在煤矿工作。当我去滑雪时，因为我得帮每个人穿衣服，
I got to make lunches for everybody because chicken tenders cost $45 up on that scheme out and Chuck Morgan don't go for that. But anyway, I said, why are you taking your clothes off? And she said, my butt hole edges. You can't get to it through all those layers. I get into it through all those. She took all their clothes up. And let me tell you all, I had been doing that on tour.
我得给每个人准备午餐，因为在那个滑雪场上鸡柳要45美元，而查克·摩根可不买账。不管怎样，我问：“你为什么要把衣服脱掉？”她说：“我屁股眼发痒。穿那么多层衣服根本够不着。”我脱了所有的衣服。我告诉你们大家，我在巡演时一直在做那个。
I've been trying to work out that band about snow skin because I hate snow. I'll go. I'll stare at rich people, but I don't ski anymore. Okay. And she said to me, Mom, can you tell people I was four or five years old? You did not tell them. They think I'm grown. And then I took my clothes off and my bum holes in.
我一直在琢磨关于雪地滑雪的那个段子，因为我讨厌雪。我会去。我会看着有钱人，但我再也不滑雪了。好吧。她对我说：“妈妈，你能告诉大家我当时四五岁吗？你别告诉他们。他们以为我已经成年了。然后我脱了衣服，我的屁股眼在发痒。”
Right. So then I had to put in there. I thought, oh, my God. So then I started saying, okay, she was a four. or five years old and her butt hole was edging. But yeah, I've had more people go, oh my gosh, that snow skin. Yeah.
对。所以我不得不插进那个。我想，哦，天哪。所以后来我开始说，好吧，她当时四五岁，她的屁股眼在发痒。但是，是的，有更多的人说，哦天哪，那种雪地滑雪。对。
Because, you know, it's so hard with little children. Oh, yeah. Did you, and now, is it true, you bring your whole family to somebody, like your Netflix special, you brought your whole family for the first time? Yes. And what are they, and what, yeah.
因为，你知道，带小孩子太难了。哦，对。你，现在，这是真的吗，你把整个家人都带到了某个地方，比如你的网飞专场，你第一次把全家人都带来了？是的。他们是什么，然后，是的。
They came out on the first one. And I just, I don't know, I just naturally thought that was the thing to do. And they'd never seen you do anything like that. No. Yeah. And they were in shock. And then I brought them out on the second one,
他们出现在第一个专场上。我只是，我不知道，我当时很自然地认为那就是该做的事。他们从来没看你做过这样的事。没有。是的。他们当时震惊了。然后我在第二个专场上把他们带了出来，
and each child now introduces me. So Charlie, my oldest, introduced me on the first one. And then Maggie, my middle child, introduced me on the second one. But y'all won't believe how many people who said, that's so sweet you brought your family out, and we want to see your family because you tell all these stories. And I don't know, it just seemed natural to me to bring them out. It really wasn't that calculated.
现在每个孩子都来介绍我出场。所以查理，我的老大，在第一个专场上介绍了我。然后玛吉，我的老二，在第二个专场上介绍了我。但你们绝对想不到有这么多人说：“你把家人带出来太甜了，我们想见见你的家人，因为你讲了那么多故事。”我不知道，带他们出来对这我来说太自然了。真的没有那么处心积虑。
I just thought, oh, look at my family. Yeah, we went on tour. I brought my sister out, and the audience was, like, thought it was like, you know, Elvis squawk on stage. we'll be right back. And back to the show. But doesn't it get a little tricky with the stories? I mean, perhaps some of them you might need to embellish to trip it into hysteria.
我只是觉得，哦，看看我的家人。对，我们去巡演了。我把姐姐带出来了，观众当时，就觉得好像是，你知道，埃尔维斯在舞台上尖叫。我们马上回来。回到节目中来。但是，这些故事不会变得有点棘手吗？我的意思是，也许其中一些你可能需要润色一下，才能达到歇斯底里的效果。
And then do some of them get a little their nose out of joint? Those like, well, you know, you always say that I'm the one that's dirty or that I'm the one that's lazy or the I'm the one that would. Like, do you have to kind of divvy it up evenly so that you don't get a bunch of heat when you get home? Yeah, yeah. You know, the only time anybody's given me any grief over it and said, do not speak my name when they went through middle school. Right. Middle school, everybody was paranoid and angry and puberty,
然后他们之中有些人会不会觉得脸上挂不住？那些人就像是，好吧，你知道的，你总是说我是那个很脏的人，或者我是那个很懒的人，或者我是那个会……之类的。你是不是得把这些平均分配一下，这样当你回到家时就不会挨一顿狂喷？对，对。你知道的，唯一一次有人因此而抱怨我，并说“不要说出我的名字”是在他们经历初中时。对。初中时，每个人都偏执、愤怒而且处于青春期，
and I did not, that was a dry time for me. That's the only, and then they got in high school and they were like, we don't care what you do. And y'all, I wasn't working that much. I mean, I was working, but it was so pitiful that nobody cared. And then college, you know, they didn't even know who I was. And then now I always say, is this okay? And now they even say to me, Mom, you've never told this story.
我没有，那对我来说是一段枯燥的时期。那是唯一的一次，然后他们上了高中，他们就觉得，你想做什么我们都不在乎。而且大家伙，我当时并没有那么拼命工作。我的意思是，我在工作，但那是如此可怜以至于没人关心。然后到了大学，你知道的，他们甚至不知道我是谁。然后现在我总是问：“这样可以吗？”现在他们甚至对我说：“妈妈，你从来没讲过这个故事。”
Tell this one. Oh, that's great. So now everybody's in on it and they're fine. The only time Chuck Morgan ever said to me, don't you ever say that again, it was one of the first times I was on stage, I'll just tell you, boys, I'd breastfed three babies. My breast looked terrible. They had sucked up into my body.
讲讲这个。哦，太棒了。所以现在大家都参与进来了，他们觉得很好。唯一一次查克·摩根对我说“你再也不许说这个了”，是我第一次上台的时候，我直说吧，小伙子们，我喂养过三个婴儿。我的胸部看起来糟糕透了。它们缩进了我的身体里。
They were like a little wadded piece of tissue with a, like, like in the bottom of a tube sock, and I had life left in me. I had life left in me. And I was 32 years old, and I wanted to get my breast done. And I said, one of the first times I was ever on stage, I said, I want to get my breast done,
它们就像一小团揉皱的纸巾，塞在管状袜子的底部，而我的生命力还在。我的生命力还在。我当时32岁，我想去做胸部整形。我说，我第一次上台时说过，我想做胸部整形，
but it's been a bad mobile home year. And Chuck Morgan said to me, don't you ever say that again? You know I can write a check for your breast today. I've always provided me. for you, and it hurt his feelings. And so I've never said anything. Well, now I say it on interviews, but now, I mean, after that, I never said it again.
但那是一个糟糕的移动房屋年。查克·摩根对我说：“你再也不许说那个了？你知道我今天就能为你开一张做手术的支票吗？我一直在供养你。”这伤害了他的感情。所以我再也没说过。好吧，我现在在采访中会说，但是现在，我的意思是，在那之后，我再也没说过。
I love that Chuck Morgan took issue with the, when you talked about a downturn in the mobile home sales. That was the only thing that bumped them out. That's so good. What a dude. That's such a dude thing. Do you guys currently have a mobile home that you guys like to travel around in? No, these are the kind, Jason.
我太喜欢查克·摩根因为你谈到移动房屋销量下滑而生气的那个梗了。那是唯一让他不爽的事。太棒了。真是个纯爷们。这真是个纯爷们会做的事。你们现在有一辆你们喜欢开着到处旅行的移动房屋吗？没有，是这种类型的，杰森。
not even those. This is the kind that you, a double wide, have you ever heard of that, my darling? This can be like a legit home. Yeah, whether you put it on a foundation. This is one of the largest home builders in the United States. Wow. And he has worked for them for over 30 years.
甚至都不是那种。这是那种你，双宽移动房屋，你听说过吗，亲爱的？这可以像个合法的家。对，无论你是把它放在地基上。这是美国最大的住宅建造商之一。哇。而且他在那儿工作了30多年。
And it is a Warren Buffett company. Yeah, yeah. They've sent us to Cancun. Oh, wow. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, boys. Yeah.
这是一个沃伦·巴菲特旗下的公司。对，对。他们把我们送到坎昆。哦，哇。对。对。对，小伙子们。对。
Jason, yeah. Jason, Jason's been on a couple motorhome. Who'd you go with, J.B.? I forget. With the Laf Garrett. We went on a nice ski tour. Oh, my Lord. Yeah, there was snow of a different kind.
杰森，对。杰森，杰森坐过几次房车。你跟谁一起去的，J.B.？我忘了。和拉夫·加勒特（Laf Garrett）一起。我们进行了一次不错的滑雪之旅。哦，天哪。对，那是另一种雪。
I've got some video of that trip I've got to find. Which I do think an RV would be fun. You had your mountain bikes with you too, didn't you? Yeah, up on the roof there. So we could travel from the mobile home lot where we'd plug in, dump the trash. and then bike into town. Oh, God. Oh, yeah.
我有些那次旅行的视频得找出来。我觉得房车会挺有意思的。你们还带着山地自行车，对吧？对，就在车顶上。这样我们就可以从我们插上电源、倒掉垃圾的移动房屋营地出发，
It's a good time. So, wait, Leanne, you were going to be, is it true you were going to be a therapist at one point? Did you study? I did study. I wanted to be a child and family therapist if I didn't make it in Hollywood. Wow.
然后骑车进城。哦，天哪。哦，是的。这是个好时光。所以，等等，莉安，你曾经打算成为，这是真的吗，你曾一度想成为一名治疗师？你学过这个吗？我学过。如果我在好莱坞没混出名堂，我想成为一名儿童和家庭治疗师。哇。
And I love all that. I still loved that. I loved my degree and I loved all that. And, you know, I looked back on it and I think during COVID, when I was wringing my hands and drinking wine and eating a chicken cassero, I should have gotten a master's on.
我喜欢这一切。我依然喜欢那个。我喜欢我的学位，我喜欢所有这些。而且，你知道，我回想起那段时光，我想在新冠疫情期间，当我急得搓手、喝着酒、吃着鸡肉砂锅时，我本应该在网上攻读硕士学位。
line. Did you get a degree in psychology? I got it in crisis intervention counseling. Wow. Wow. Wow. That's kind of cool. After I went back, y'all, after I went back and got through all that bad time,
你拿的是心理学学位吗？我拿的是危机干预咨询学位。哇。哇。哇。这挺酷的。在我回去之后，大家伙，在我回去经历完所有那些糟糕的时光之后，
then I buckled down and studied. But yeah. It makes me think, like, you know, sometimes when you see, like, one of my favorite movies is King of Comedy when Jerry Lewis played a very sort of severe, serious, talk show host behind the scenes. And, you know, comics, particularly stand-up comics, always have this exciting, darker, quiet side. Do you, I start thinking about, like, this degree you've got and therapy,
然后我静下心来学习。但是，是的。这让我想起，你知道，有时当你看到，比如我最喜欢的电影之一是《喜剧之王》，杰瑞·刘易斯（Jerry Lewis）在幕后扮演了一个非常严厉、严肃脱口秀主持人。而且，你知道的，喜剧演员，尤其是单口喜剧演员，总是有一种令人兴奋的、更黑暗的、安静的一面。你会，我开始联想到，比如你拿到的这个学位和治疗，
you know, do you ever fantasize about playing a role where it's dark and it's quiet and there's sort of this flip side to the character? Do you have, like, acting aspirations like that? I do, Jason. And y'all would know better than I do if I could even do it. I bet you'd be great. But I would love to do drama and I would love to do a darker character. You'd be great.
你知道，你有没有幻想过扮演一个黑暗、安静、角色有这种反面特质的角色？你有没有过这样的表演追求？我有，杰森。而且你们比我更清楚我是否能做到这一点。我敢打赌你会演得很棒。但我很想演正剧，我很想演一个更黑暗的角色。你会很棒的。
You can't do what you do without that side being under at all. We get it. We know what you're doing. You should get after that. Thank you, my darling. I would love to. I don't know if anybody would take me seriously. Sure, they would be exciting as hell.
没有那种潜藏的一面，你根本做不出你现在做的事。我们懂。我们知道你在干什么。你应该去争取这个。谢谢你，亲爱的。我很想去。我不知道是否会有人把我当回事。当然会，那刺激透了。
Jason, the big-time director. Jason, what are we talking about here? Big time, big-time. You are. You are. You are. Big, big, big, big, big, big. You are.
杰森，大导演。杰森，我们在这说什么呢？大牌，大牌。你就是。你就是。你就是。大、大、大、大、大、大。你就是。
Yes. But, no, that would be, that would be very cool. So, you know, more exciting, even more so now that everyone is so excited and familiar with the flip side of it, and you show them what's behind the curtain, Leanne. I would love that. I love that. Leanne, you said, there's so many little tiny things. Like, you love doing laundry, which is like, what?
是的。但是，不，那会很酷，很酷。所以，你知道，更令人兴奋，现在大家对这枚硬币的另一面如此兴奋和熟悉，你把幕后的东西展现给他们看，莉安。我会很喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。莉安，你刚才说，有那么多微小的事情。比如，你喜欢洗衣服，这简直是，什么？
He loves doing laundry. It's therapeutic. And then, and gas station, your favorite gas station snack on tour, because I have. You love grabbing stuff at gas stations, like when you're on tour. What's your classic snack? Well, honey, we have to. I don't want a boiled egg, but I have to try to because I don't want my butt to look big on TV. That was a shock, boys.
他喜欢洗衣服。这有治疗作用。然后，还有加油站，你在巡演中最喜欢的加油站零食，因为我有。你喜欢在加油站买东西，比如你在巡演的时候。你的经典零食是什么？好吧，亲爱的，我们必须这样做。我不想要水煮蛋，但我得尽量吃，因为我不想让我的屁股在电视上看起来很大。这太让人震惊了，小伙子们。
That was a shock. You know what I don't like. Where's my chin? I don't like boiled nuts, which you see a lot in the South. Like warm nuts? No, no, boiled. Like they're in like a bag, like a bag. a wet freaking bag
这太让人震惊了。你知道我不喜欢什么。我的下巴呢？我不喜欢水煮花生，你在南方经常能看到这种东西。像温热的花生？不，不，水煮的。就像它们在一个袋子里，在一个袋子里。一个湿乎乎他妈的袋子，
that makes the peanut shell all soft and sometimes they're a little spicy and so. And I, I'm a big peanut fan and so I tried to get into it over and over again there in Georgia all the years I've spent there. I just can't get there, but I feel like it might be
把花生壳泡得软绵绵的，有时候它们还有点辣，所以。而且，我是一个狂热的花生迷，所以在乔治亚州我度过的所有那些年里，我一次又一次地尝试去接受它。我就是接受无能，但我感觉它可能已经
close. No? No. Don't stop trying. I've never cared about a bowl peanut. Yeah. I try to eat nuts, you know, because they, you know, a handful of nuts I don't want to get dementia or whatever, but I don't. Wait, does that help? Do nuts help with the...
接近了？不？不。别放弃尝试。我从来不在乎什么水煮花生。对。我试着吃坚果，你知道的，因为它们，你知道，一把坚果，我不想得痴呆症什么的，等等，但我没有。等等，这有帮助吗？坚果对……有帮助吗？
I think some, like walnuts and brain health, I think so. Omega's something. Omega's in there? But now Chuck Morgan, now Chuck Morgan can go to a gas station, make a full meal with boiled eggs, and because it's cheaper and relish and a mayo packet and make his own egg salad. But being on tour, you all know what that is.
我觉得有些，比如核桃对大脑健康有益，我觉得是的。欧米伽什么的。里面有欧米伽？但现在查克·摩根，现在查克·摩根去加油站，能用煮鸡蛋凑合出一顿丰盛的饭，因为更便宜，再加上酱菜和一包蛋黄酱，他就能自制鸡蛋沙拉。但在巡演中，你们都知道那是什么情况。
I'm constantly trying to get, you know, trying to get in protein because I'm 60. Now everybody yells about women having all that protein, but it's hard on the road. Who's cooking in the house? Does Chuck know how to throw a meal together when Mama comes home, super tired from all over, just hammering it? He can make do.
我一直在努力摄入，你知道的，努力摄入蛋白质，因为我都60岁了。现在每个人都在大谈特谈女性摄入所有这些蛋白质的重要性，但在路上这太难了。家里是谁在做饭？当妈妈结束了到处奔波、累得要死、拼命干活回到家时，查克会做饭吗？他能凑合。
Yeah. Because I, y'all, I was the stay-at-home mom, and even though I was doing stand-up, I cooked every meal. I am a country. I'm from the country. We cook. We put everything into these children. I was doing all that and doing everything, you know, because he was trapped.
对。因为我，大家伙，我曾是个全职妈妈，尽管我在做单口喜剧，但我每一顿饭都自己做。我是个乡下人。我来自乡下。我们做饭。我们把一切都倾注在这些孩子身上。我做着所有这些事，把一切都包揽了，你知道的，因为他被困住了。
That house always smells so yummy. What's your go-to meal? Fancy folks coming over and you want to really wow them with how you can make this particular. Oh, y'all, I don't feel like, I don't feel very fancy, but. No, it doesn't need to be a fancy dish. These people need not be fancy. With something you know you make well. Yeah, if you're looking to brag a little bit.
那栋房子总是闻起来那么香。你的拿手菜是什么？有讲究的人来做客，你想用你拿手的一道菜惊艳他们。哦，大家伙，我感觉自己一点也不讲究，但是……不，不需要多华丽的菜。这些人不需要太讲究。做你擅长的某道菜就行。对，如果你想稍微炫耀一下的话。
I can make a good chicken pucata. Oh. Oh, look at that with the capers? Sure. With the capers, lemon, with a thin chicken breast. Mm-hmm. I can do that with a little angel hair. There's a lot of water retention on the capers.
我会做一道不错的意式柠檬鸡（chicken piccata）。哦。哦，看那个，加了酸豆（capers）的？当然。加了酸豆、柠檬，用薄薄的鸡胸肉。嗯哼。我可以用这个配一点天使发面（angel hair pasta）。酸豆里有很多水分潴留。
Is there really? Yeah. My friend Josh, our friend Josh, he once told me that he ate chicken piccata, I think, something like 87 days in a row and a real low point in his life. He was looking a little puffy through a few months. Leanne, who's outside of your family and Chuck? Morgan, who's your best, who's your friend that makes you the laugh the hardest or who makes you just gaggle? I tell you, the Karen Mills, who is a stand-up, who's been doing it longer than I
真的吗？是的。我的朋友乔希，我们的朋友乔希，他曾经告诉我，他连续吃了大约87天的意式柠檬鸡，那是他人生中的一个低谷。在那几个月里，他看起来有点浮肿。莉安，除了你的家人和查克·摩根之外，谁是你最好的朋友，谁是那个能让你笑得最大声或者让你咯咯直笑的朋友？我告诉你，凯伦·米尔斯（Karen Mills），她是一个单口喜剧演员，干这行比我
have, has been my saving grace in this whole thing. Because imagine y'all, my girlfriends, you know, their husbands are executives, they're out playing tennis, they're all, you know, getting new countertops. And I love them. And I love them, but they don't understand the comedy mind. You know, you've got to be around other comedians. And Karen Mills opens for me on tour, not all the time because she's got her own thing going on. But I can't tell y'all how I'm grateful I am to have her. We laugh so hard together.
还久，她一直是我在这件事上的救星。因为想象一下，大家伙，我的女友们，你知道的，她们的丈夫都是高管，她们出去打网球，她们都在，你知道的，换新的台面。我爱她们。我爱她们，但她们不懂喜剧的思维。你知道的，你必须和别的喜剧演员在一起。凯伦·米尔斯在巡演时为我暖场，也不是每次都去，因为她有她自己的事要忙。但我无法向你们表达我是多么感激能有她。我们在一起笑得太厉害了。
You know, I'd go back and forth with her about material. And then when we've had, through the years, I had to do a lot of private corporate things because I had three children and couldn't stay gone. And I would do a gig and then call her and say, I'm quitting. That was the worst thing. that's ever happened to me. I wish somebody had shot me while I was on stage. And she would call me on the way home from a horrible gig and say, I'm quitting. I'd go, no, you're not. But we had each other. And, you know,
你知道的，我会跟她交流段子。然后这些年来，我不得不做很多私人的企业演出，因为我有三个孩子，不能离开太久。我会去演一场，然后打电话给她说：“我要不干了。这是我经历过最糟糕的事。我希望有人在我上台时把我枪毙了。”她会在结束一场糟糕的演出回家的路上打电话给我说：“我要不干了。”我会说：“不，你才没有。”但我们拥有彼此。而且，你知道的，
it really helped me to have somebody, because I'm in Knoxville, Tennessee. And I'm not around in Nashville. I work Zanis all the time, and my concert promoters are out of Nashville. Nashville's a huge comedy scene now with Nate Burgessie, John Christ, Theo Vaughn, all these people. And I get to be with them, but all these years I was on my own. And this mom, you know, when everybody else was talking about school stuff and stuff that I was involved to with my kids, but I needed somebody that understood what I was going through
有一个人真的帮了我很大忙，因为我住在田纳西州诺克斯维尔。我不在纳什维尔。我一直在扎尼斯（Zanis）演出，我的演唱会推广商都在纳什维尔。纳什维尔现在是一个巨大的喜剧重镇，有内特·巴加茨（Nate Bargatze）、约翰·克赖斯特（John Crist）、特奥·冯（Theo Vonn），所有人都在那儿。我能和他们在一起，但这些年来我都是孤身一人。这位妈妈，你知道的，当其他人在谈论学校的事情以及与我的孩子有关的事情时，我需要一个理解我正在经历什么的人，
because it's hard. Stand up is hard. The hardest. You know, and you drive 300 miles and make $50 and all that kind of stuff. How do you handle when you're saying, like, sometimes, like, some of those gigs, it's just the worst, somebody shoot me. You're like, how do you handle that when the audience is just not, like they're distracted, they're talking, they're drinking, maybe they're having a meal or whatever.
因为这太难了。单口喜剧太难了。最难的。你知道的，你开车300英里只赚50美元诸如此类的事。当你遇到这种情况时，比如有时，其中一些演出简直糟透了，真想让人枪毙我，你是怎么处理的？当观众根本不——比如他们分心了，他们在聊天，他们在喝酒，也许他们在吃东西或者别的什么。
Like, do they ever get nasty? Do you ever feel like, well, fuck this. I'm going to engage with these people and like get after them a little bit or maybe a heckler or something. Does it ever get, like, not fun and contentious? It's not fun. And there's times when you feel gutted, you know, coming out of doing a show for men that make carpet fiber.
他们会变得很讨厌吗？你会不会觉得，好吧，去他妈的。我要和这些人互动一下，稍微收拾他们一下，或者应对一个起哄者什么的？这会变得不好玩并充满争执吗？这并不好玩。有时候你会觉得心如刀割，你知道的，给那些制造地毯纤维的男人演出下来之后。
But then, but I don't get contentious. I don't go there, Jason, because I'm too sissy. If I started, you know, going after somebody,
但是，但是我也不会去争辩。我不会那样做，杰森，因为我太胆小了。如果我开始，你知道的，去找某个人的麻烦，
then if they came after me, then I don't feel, and people have never heckled me. Like, I only get like a drunk woman saying, I got a C-section. You know, I get that kind of stuff. I don't get, you know, people coming after me.
如果他们反过来找我麻烦，那我就觉得不妙了，而且从来没有人起哄过我。比如，我只会遇到一个喝醉的女人说：“我有剖腹产疤痕。”你知道的，我只会遇到那种情况。我不会遇到，你知道的，人们来找我麻烦。
And I think it's because I'm a mom and people are, and they can tell I've got a sweet spirit. And they don't want to come after me. Yeah, good. Right, right, right. But, yeah, some of these corporate things will kill you. What about cursing?
我想这是因为我是个妈妈，人们能看出我有一颗温柔的心。他们不想来找我麻烦。对，很好。对，对，对。但是，是的，其中一些企业演出能把你折磨死。关于说脏话呢？
Do you ever, do you, there's a, there's some, there are comics that curse and comics that don't, correct? Isn't there? There's like, there's a demarcation line there. Yeah. And I don't, and I love, like, I'm a huge fan of Dave Chappelle. Oh, my gosh, I love, I love all kinds of comedy, and I don't care if they cuss. I've never done it. But I think it's because I started out, you know, with little children.
你会不会，你，有些喜剧演员说脏话，有些不说，对吧？难道不是吗？那里有一条分界线。是的。我不说，我喜欢，比如，我是戴夫·查佩尔（Dave Chappelle）的超级粉丝。哦，天哪，我喜欢，我喜欢各种各样的喜剧，我不在乎他们说不说脏话。我从来没说过。但我想这是因为我一开始，你知道的，带着小孩子，
and I didn't want to say anything that I didn't want them to say. It's almost funnier without it. And it just wasn't in my thing, you know, but I don't mind it when other people do it. But yeah, there is kind of a, there's a line. Yeah, it's like, I always love that about Nate, too. You mentioned Nate Bergatsi, who I love. He's such a good dude, and he's so funny and he never cusses.
我不想说任何我不想让他们说的话。不用脏话反而更好笑。而且这本来就不在我的风格里，你知道的，但我不介意别人这么做。不过是的，确实有一种，有一条界限。是的，就像，我一直很喜欢内特这一点，也是。你提到了内特·巴加茨，我很喜欢他。他是个极好的家伙，他太搞笑了而且他从不说脏话。
It's amazing. It doesn't, huh? Yeah. We shut up. No, I don't know. I don't know. No, he doesn't. Leanne, we're going to do some rapid fire,
太神奇了。没有，是吗？对。我们闭嘴。不，我不知道。我不知道。不，他没有。莉安，我们要进行一轮快问快答，
and then I'm going to ask you one last question. Okay, ready? Okay, my darling. Is it rapid fire? Is it a new section? We're doing a new section? Yeah. Do we need like some sting music to Tia?
然后我要问你最后一个问题。好吧，准备好了吗？好的，亲爱的。这是快问快答吗？这是一个新环节？我们在做一个新环节？对。我们需要一点刺痛音乐（Sting music）来配合吗？
I love this. Sure. You're going to be a little thing music. Rob, Rob, drop us up some. Sean's Rapid Fire section. There's only like five of them. Ready? Sweet to your bourbon.
我喜欢这个。当然。你会有一段小音乐。罗布，罗布，给我们来一点。肖恩的快问快答环节。总共也就五个左右。准备好了吗？甜的配波旁威士忌。
I'd even say bourbon. Oh, I love that. Jella salad or banana pudding? Banana pudding. Country music concert or arena rock show. Or what kind of rock show? Like a big arena rock show. Arena rock show.
我甚至不会说波旁威士忌。哦，我爱那个。杰洛果冻沙拉（Jello salad）还是香蕉布丁？香蕉布丁。乡村音乐演唱会还是体育馆摇滚秀。或者什么样的摇滚秀？比如大型体育馆摇滚秀。体育馆摇滚秀。
Like the journey. need to death of everything. I'd probably go for a rock show. Oh, wow. Live studio audience or on location or like touring or something? Live studio audience. How about that? Early bird or night owl? Early bird. Oh, wow. Pizza or barbecue ribs? Pizza. Pancakes or bacon? Peacques. Levi's or Lycra? Levi's. Boy, I answered all of them the same. I'm just listing all the stuff that's in front of them right now, by the way. He's just looking at stuff in his room. Pizza and rims, Lycra and jeans. He's just looking at shit that's in his view.
就像“旅行”乐队（Journey）。致死的一切。我可能会选摇滚秀。哦，哇。现场演播室观众还是外景地或者巡演什么的？现场演播室观众。怎么样？早起鸟还是夜猫子？早起鸟。哦，哇。披萨还是烤排骨？披萨。煎饼还是培根？煎饼。李维斯（Levi's）还是莱卡（Lycra）？李维斯。天哪，我所有问题都选了一样的。顺便说一句，我只是在列出他们眼前所有的东西。他只是在看他房间里的东西。
There's an open box of pizza in the corner. Banana pudding. He's like, I'm going to get after that banana pudding. Leanne, I want to leave you with the first of all, this has been so great. I just want you to say, you know, you said your message is over and over again is about women of a certain age, as you said.
角落里有一盒打开的披萨。香蕉布丁。他就像是，我要去吃那个香蕉布丁。莉安，我想把这个问题留给你——首先，这次太棒了。我只想让你说，你知道的，你刚才说你的信息一遍又一遍是关于特定年龄的女性，正如你所说。
It's not over for us. What does that mean? What would you tell your younger self about that? Growing up, by the way, we didn't even talk about you moving to a town called Bean Station. But anyway, Bean Station. I just, I'll grant y'all, being in Hollywood with these young girls that are, and these actresses,
对我们来说还没结束。这到底意味着什么？你会对年轻时的自己说些什么？顺便说一句，成长过程中，我们甚至没聊到你搬到一个叫宾站（Bean Station）的小镇。但是不管怎样，宾站。我只是，我向你们保证，在好莱坞和这些年轻女孩以及这些女演员在一起，
first of all, if I'd have moved to Hollywood at 20, I'd be on dope. Let me say that. I don't know how they've done it. I think, you know, because I'm 60 years old and who I am, that I'm able to handle all this. But I tell young women all the time because they all think, and I remember feeling at 30, like I'm old and 40, it's over.
首先，如果我20岁搬到好莱坞，我早就吸毒了。我这么说吧。我不知道她们是怎么做到的。我想，你知道的，因为我60岁了，我知道我是谁，所以我能够应付这一切。但我总是告诉年轻女性，因为她们都觉得，我记得30岁时觉得自己老了，40岁时就结束了。
And I feel like I'm smarter than I've ever been. I'm better at my craft. It took me 20 years to figure out how to do this. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I just think it makes sense when people make it big. Like Bill Burr, I heard him in an interview say, it took me 20 years. I couldn't sell tickets.
而我觉得自己比以往任何时候都更聪明。我对我的手艺更精通了。我花了20年才弄明白怎么做这行。对，对，对，对。而且我只是觉得当人们一举成名时这很有道理。比如比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr），我听他在一个采访中说，我花了20年。我卖不出票。
I couldn't do anything. And it was a slow build, but who I am and why it's happening to me, you know, all this has happened to me at this age. I just think it's crazy to think that, and I know y'all have been big deal since y'all were young, and that's wonderful. And you've given so much joy to all of us. But I do think there's something about, you know, honing a craft and... And learn, like you said, learn, like you're at 60, you know three times as much as a 20-year-old.
我什么也做不了。这是一个缓慢的积累，但我是谁，为什么这会发生在我身上，你知道的，这一切都发生在我这个年龄，我只是觉得认为这已经结束是很疯狂的，我知道你们俩从年轻时就是大人物了，那太棒了。你们给我们所有人都带来了那么多欢乐。但我确实认为，打磨一门手艺……还有学习，就像你说的，学习，就像你到了60岁，你的知识量是20岁年轻人的三倍。
And so that informs the things you can access when you're talking about funny shit. You know, it just like makes so much more sense. I'm still doing the multiplication after Jason just said that. Yeah, it's also a privilege to get older, you know, like, because the only other choice is dying. I know. Right, right. It's like you want to get as old as possible because if you don't, you die. You're dead.
所以这会丰富你在谈论搞笑事情时能够调用资源。你知道的，这让一切都顺理成章。在杰森说完刚才那句话之后，我还在做乘法运算呢。对，变老也是一种特权，你知道的，因为唯一的另一个选择就是死亡。我知道。对，对。这就像你想活得越老越好，因为如果你不这样，你就死了。你死定了。
I know. That's your choice. Those are your choices. Bring the wrinkles on. That's why eating those two cakes and that stretched out tin kini swims skirt. meant the world to me. I thought 60 was going to be rough on me, and I thought, oh, my gosh, I'm so thankful to have my health and I'm having the time of my life.
我知道。那是你的选择。这就是你的选择。让皱纹来吧。这就是为什么吃那两块蛋糕和穿着那条松垮的泳裙对我来说意义重大。我以为60岁对我来说会很难熬，然后我想，哦，天哪，我很感激自己拥有健康，我正在过着我一生中最快乐的时光。
This is crazy what's happening to me. It's like winning the lottery. It's like God's put down at the carnival and picked up one of those little ducks and said, it's you, girl. You know, I just feel so blessed by all of it. You're doing it real well, and this has been an enormous pleasure. Thank you.
发生在我身上的这一切太疯狂了。就像中彩票一样。就像上帝在狂欢节上弯下腰，捡起其中一只小鸭子说：“就是你，小姑娘。”你知道的，我对这一切感到无比的祝福。你干得真漂亮，这真是一次巨大的荣幸。谢谢你。
Sean, be honest. Be honest. Did it make you think about or getting a cake today? 100% I just wrote it down. You did. And I put it too next to it. Leanne, you are, you can see why you made it.
肖恩，说实话。说实话。这有没有让你想起或者今天去弄个蛋糕？100% 我刚刚写下来了。你写了。我还在它旁边写了个“2”。莉安，你真是，你能看出为什么你能成功。
You're just an absolute unbelievable joy. Thank you. All your success is so deserved. It's so awesome to talk with you. Thanks for talking to us today. Thank you all. I'm in love with all three of y'all. Back at you.
你绝对是一个令人难以置信的开心果。谢谢你。你所有的成功都是实至名归的。和聊天太棒了。谢谢你今天跟我们聊天。谢谢你们大家。我爱死你们三个了。彼此彼此。
Y'all are darling. Y'all have given so much joy. I hope y'all know that. To all of us people out here, in the middle of the United States. Let us know when you're going to do a set out here in Los Angeles. Yeah. Okay.
你们太可爱了。你们带来了那么多的欢乐。我希望你们知道这一点。带给我们美国中部这里的这群人。让我们知道什么时候你们要在洛杉矶这边做一场演出。好的。
I will. I'll be working on that new hour, Jason. Come on. All right, you, angel. You angel. Thank you for this today. Thank you, my love. Have a great rest of your day, Leanne.
会的。我会创作那个新的那一小时节目的，杰森。来吧。好的，你这个天使。你这个天使。谢谢你今天的到来。谢谢你，亲爱的。祝你余下的时光过得愉快，莉安。
Thank you, Leah. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. Bye. Sean, what a great guest. I know, she was great. You know, Scotty loves her. Lives her. And I did too, but, I mean,
谢谢你，莉安。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。再见。肖恩，多棒的嘉宾啊。我知道，她太棒了。你知道的，斯科蒂（Scotty）爱死她了。爱死她了。我也一样，但是，我的意思是，
He's seen every single thing she's ever done. Scotty turned you on to her? Yeah. And I was like, wow, she is really funny. She's really funny. I can hear her talking about Chuck Morgan all day. I know. He comes up a lot.
他看过她做过的每一件事。是斯科蒂让你粉上她的？对。然后我就想，哇，她真的很搞笑。她真的太搞笑了。我听她聊查克·摩根能聊一整天。我知道。他经常出现。
He's got to come out on stage. Wouldn't that be fun? I want to talk to that guy. Book him. All right, book him. Don't shout it. Don't shout orders. Hey, are you going to bring a cake over tonight?
他得出来上台。那不是挺有意思的吗？我想跟那家伙聊聊。预约他。好吧，预约他。别大喊大叫的。别在这发号施令。嘿，你今晚要带个蛋糕过来吗？
Do you want me to? Yeah, or a pie. Once you go get a, I'll go get a sweet lady, Jane's, Or a cake or something. Or a Winston's pie? Will you really eat it if I get it? If you get a Winston's pie, I'm going to eat the hell out of it.
你想让我带吗？对，或者一个派。你去买一个，我去买个甜蜜简（Sweet Lady Jane）的。或者一个蛋糕什么的？或者温斯顿派（Winston's pie）？如果我买的话你真的会吃吗？如果你买温斯顿派，我他妈一定会把它吃光。
They're okay. You're not a pie guy. You're more of a cake guy? Yeah, pie. I don't understand pie. It's just fruit shoved into pastry. All right, well, then bring a cake. Yeah.
它们还行。你不是个派爱好者？你更喜欢蛋糕？对，派。我不理解派。那不就是塞进面皮里的水果吗？好吧，那就带个蛋糕。对。
Yeah. That I understand. What are we watching? You said. Oh, right, right, right, right. Are you guys getting together tonight? Yeah. I don't watch a movie.
对。那个我懂。我们在看什么？你刚才说。哦，对，对，对，对。你们今晚要聚在一起吗？对。我不看电影。
Yeah. Now, Will, aren't you supposed to come home? You're supposed to come home for a week and then go back to a Long Island. Yeah. Is that going to happen? I'm coming back Friday. For? A week, eight days.
对。现在，威尔，你不是应该回家吗？你应该回家呆一周，然后再回长岛。是的。那会发生吗？我周五回来。为了？一周，八天。
Yeah. Wait, really? Is there any way that you can free up for some hangout with Danny D's on Sunday morning? No, I can't Sunday. God damn it. I know. What about Saturday morning with me? Saturday.
是的。等等，真的吗？你有没有可能在周日早上空出时间跟丹尼·D聚聚？不，我周日不行。该死。我知道。那我周六早上呢？周六。
Oh, that's sweet. No, I can't. Because I got that thing that you can't do Saturday afternoon that you said that you can't do. I can't. That's why I'm going to cram in the ground in the morning. I can't. Because I have two. I have other shit.
哦，太贴心了。不，我不行。因为我有那个你周六下午不能去、你也说去不了的事情。我不行。这就是为什么我打算早上把事情塞满。我不行。因为我有两个。我有别的事。
I don't think you're going through your schedule right now. Are we still rolling? Yeah. Damn it. Well, hey, what about that Leanne Morgan? I know, I know. Oh, she was an absolute delight. She's a delight.
我觉得你现在没有看你的日程表。我们还在录吗？在的。该死。好吧，嘿，那个莉安·摩根呢？我知道，我知道。哦，她绝对是个开心果。她是个开心果。
I mean, maybe late Sunday afternoon. Sorry, yes, Leanne Morgan. You know, I must say, Willie, you are, you are, you're gone for a long, long time with this junk and I'm this incredible movie that you're in. I can't wait for everybody to see you in it. When do you think you're, when do you, when will you be done? Bye. Bye. Love you all.
我是说，也许周日傍晚。对不起，是的，莉安·摩根。你知道，我必须说，威利，你为了拍这些垃圾和你参演的那部不可思议的电影，离开好久好久。我等不及让所有人都看到你的表演了。你觉得你什么时候，你什么时候能拍完？再见。再见。爱你们。
Bye. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico. and Michael Grant Terry. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。Smartless。《Smartless》由罗伯·阿尔姆贾夫、本内特·巴巴里科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里纯天然手工制作。Smartless。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。